Das war's für heute. Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Nice!
Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Ich hoffe, das Video euch gefallen hat.
Wenn ihr gerne weitere Videos anschaut,
dann abonniert meinen Kanal,
fitsch und schreibt mir in die Kommentare.
Moin Leute, wir probieren heute mal ein paar Linux Sachen aus, ich muss aber erstmal schnell
mein Headset entwirren. So, und ihr kennt mich ja, ich mag so die Linux Sachen sehr minimalistisch,
allerdings nicht so minimalistisch, dass es einmal auf den Sack geht. Also ja, ich hab da schon so...
eigentlich habe ich nicht wirklich... ich bin nicht erkältet, nee nee. Ich höre mich wahrscheinlich
so an wie immer. Ich bin gerade die Treppe hochgeflitzt, das ist alles. So, was wollte ich jetzt
sagen? Also, ihr wisst ja, ich mag das unter Linux teilweise gerne da minimalistisch. Ich
habe ja mein Manjaro i3 WM schon seit ganz langer Zeit, aber es gibt ein paar Sachen,
die wollte ich mal ausprobieren. Hat nicht unbedingt was jetzt irgendwie mit der Distributionswahl
direkt zu tun. Also ein paar Sachen, die ich ausprobieren wollte. Ja, ich zeige euch mal so
eine Liste, was ich ausprobieren wollte. Also und zwar... was habe ich denn? Hier, so. Gibt
so ein paar Sachen, die wollte ich mal ausprobieren. Zum Beispiel, ich verwende seit Ewigkeiten
den Pure Prompt. Allerdings Starship ist jetzt so der neueste Shit. Das hier ist ein Package
Manager, ein Metapackage Manager. Das sind Config Files Manager und T-Maxx haben wir
schon. Und ich wollte mir mal ein paar neue Terminals angucken. Also aktuell sieht es
ja bei mir so aus. Ich habe gerade ein MassifP Profet gefuddert. Aktuell sieht es ja bei
mir so aus. Da, das wird nicht lange halten. Da bin ich mir relativ sicher, das hält nicht
lange. Was will eigentlich dieses Kack denn jedes Mal machen? Also aktuell sieht es bei
mir so aus. Das ist ein Gnome Terminal, T-Maxx und das ist I3 auf einem Manjaro mit, ich
mache den ganzen Krempel mal kurz zu hier, auf einem Manjaro mit ZSH und Pure Prompt
heißt das Ding, glaube ich. Kurz gucke. Pure Prompt. Ja und Pure Prompt. Ich wollte mal
ein paar andere Sachen ausprobieren. Und was man damit theoretisch verbinden kann, ist,
wir müssten ja echt mal eine neue Streaming-Vorm installieren. Vielleicht machen wir noch
schnell eine Arch-By-The-Way-Installation vorher. Und wir müssen mal gucken. Ja, ich
glaube, das machen wir jetzt. Ich hatte vor einer Weile schon mal was installiert. Was
heißt vor einer Weile? Vor einer Weile, vor ein paar Stunden oder so, habe ich so ein
Minimal-Ding schon vor einer Weile. Das hört sich jetzt an, als war das letztes Jahr oder
so. Keine Ahnung, vor einer Stunde oder so habe ich schon mal neue VM installiert. Aber
wir können das auch schnell im Stream zusammen machen. Arch-By-The-Way installieren. I3 drauf
klatschen. Wir brauchen jetzt übrigens keinen. Passt mal auf, ich habe hier noch I3-Gaps.
I3-Gaps ist outdated, overrated, jebaited. Ja, I3-Gaps brauchen wir nicht mehr, weil
die haben es tatsächlich geschafft, dass der Patch für die Gaps ist jetzt im normalen
I3-WM drinne. Man braucht jetzt keinen Gaps mehr. Warum das gefühlt 15 Jahre Sway geht
nicht in der VM gescheitert. Weil Sway ist Wayland und Wayland funktioniert in VM-Wer-Beziehungsweise
generell in VMs mehr schlecht als recht. Na, ich mag Gaps. Also, was ist der Unterschied
zwischen I3-WM und I3-Gaps? Naja, I3-Gaps hatte den Patch drinne, dass man solche Lücken
zwischen den Fenstern haben kann. Also, wenn ich jetzt mehrere Fenster habe, dann sind
die schön getrennt mit Lücken. Das kann der normale I3, konnte der normale I3 bisher
nicht. Xetodanch für den Zap. Ja, das konnte der normale bisher nicht. Aber jetzt angeblich
funktioniert das. Komm, wir legen eine neue VM an. Wir müssen uns bestimmt ein paar Sachen
hier rauskopieren, aber machen wir mal. Also, ich werde auch bei X11 bleiben, bis es nicht
mehr geht, beziehungsweise bis Wayland ordentlich funktioniert in der VM. Leute, also jedes
Mal, das ist ja der Witz, jedes Mal, wenn ich Wayland in der VM ausprobiere, ist das absoluter
Reihenfall. NixOS. Ist NixOS das mit den ganzen Containern oder? Nee, oder? Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht. Also, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wozu. Was ist das? Ist das nicht
das Container Zeug? Warum? Also, was hat das für? Für wie sagt man so? Selling Points?
Ja, lange nicht mehr da gewesen. Stimmt. Stripes, es gibt jetzt neue Qt-Emotes. Sowas
hier zum Beispiel. Snapshot Zeug, naja gut. Kannst du jetzt mit dem neuen Rechner viele
VMs gleichzeitig fahren? Also, ganz im Ernst, mit dem neuen Rechner, kann ich wahrscheinlich.
Sieht das hier schon wieder so kacke aus. Also, mit dem neuen Rechner kann ich wahrscheinlich
100 VMs starten oder so, wenn ich denen nicht alle irgendwie 16G RAM gebe und voll auslaste.
Es sollte gerade so reichen. Wisst ihr was? Wir machen das jetzt. Bam. Also, auf geht's.
Wie viel hat denn das Ding? Wie viel hat denn das Ding? 130, 60, null alter, null. Das geht
besser. Das geht besser. Okay, okay. Ach, übrigens Leute, ich habe Upgraded. Ich bin
jetzt auf neuestem VM-Build. Guck, ich bin jetzt neuestes VM-Build. 16, 17, irgendwas.
Wobei, bin ich wirklich auf dem allerneuesten? Lass mal kurz checken. Tatsächlich, ich bin
auf dem allerneuesten. Wieder Software-Kong. Nee, diesmal nicht Software-Kong. Aber auch
nicht offizielles VMWare. Offizielles VMWare kostet 100, 140 Euro. Key Seller kostet VMWare
1,8 oder so. Also, da geht einiges. Was ist da los? Keine Ahnung, was weiß ich. Jetzt
kommen die Leute schon wieder hinter. Max, Max, hast du da etwa eine Sicherheitskopie
laufen? Nein, ich habe keine Sicherheitskopie laufen. Aber was heißt eine Sicherheitskopie?
Wenn eine Sicherheitskopie ist runtergeladen von der Herstellerseite, dann habe ich eine
Sicherheitskopie laufen. Ich habe einen ganz normalen Key. Allerdings nicht von VMWare,
sondern von irgendeinem Seller. Wo der Seller den Key her hat, habe ich keine Ahnung. Das
interessiert mich auch nicht. Das letzte Mal habe ich bei Software-Kong den Key gekauft.
Das klang auch schon super vertrauenswürdig. Wahrscheinlich haben sie den Key nachts ausgeraubt
mit Lizenz-Keys drin. Was weiß ich. Ich frage mich eh wann VMWare das unterbindet und das
direkt koppelt an einen VMWare-Account. Also JetBrains macht es ja beispielsweise jetzt
schon seit einem Jahr, dass du dich mit einem JetBrains-Account einloggen musst. Ansonsten
ist das eigentlich das neue Normal fast schon. Aber VMWare hält da fest dran. Wir probieren
heute noch ein paar Sachen aus. Und eins habe ich noch vergessen. Wie heißt das? ZeteliJ
oder sowas. Das habe ich auch auf GitHub gefunden. Weiß nicht wie man das genau schreibt. Irgendwie
so. Das ist quasi so T-Max-Alternativ. Wir machen jetzt erstmal eine neue VM. Früher
oder später muss das eh sein. Manjaro ist out. Alle haten Manjaro. Wir haten Manjaro
jetzt mit uns. Übrigens, mal für alle Leute, die Windows 11 verwenden und das neueste VMWare.
Also wenn ihr auch VMWare 17 habt oder VMWare 16.2, da gibt es einen Bug. Ich zeige euch
das mal, falls ihr auch die Probleme habt. VMWare Linux-Lag. Hier. Noticeable Typing-Lag
in der Linux. So, und es scheint nämlich so zu sein, sobald man... Was war denn Endeavor
OS nochmal? Ist das Arch-based? Arch, by the way, Arch-based. Okay, hat das einen i3-Spin-off?
Hat das i3? Aha. Haben wir das schon mal ausprobiert? Taugt das? Taugt das? Standard-Art-Schrepus,
ja, das ist mir ganz recht. Ich fände es cool, wenn i3, wenn ich irgendeine Distribution
finde... Was ist denn Hyperland? Hyperland Linux. Dynamic-Tiling-Wayland. Ich kann nicht
Wayland verwenden in der VM. Das funktioniert nicht. Das ist sprocken. Wayland ist verbuggt
in der VM. Auf mehrere Arten. Der beste Bug ist, dass sich der Screen nicht refresht
von selber. Stellt euch mal vor, wo kämen wir da hin, wenn sich der Screen von selbst
refresht? Da könnte man ja tatsächlich was anzeigen, außer ein statisches Bild. Also
Wayland refresht den Screen nicht in der VM. Das kann man fixen, indem man irgendwelche
Dinge überschreibt. Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr genau. Das kann man fixen. Und
spätestens aber Copy-Paste hört auf. Also probieren wir mal, was VMWare, Wayland, Copy-Paste.
Mal gucken, ob das mittlerweile geht. Copy in text to host from VMWare doesn't work. Copy-Paste
is not working. Okay. Open. Nice. Copy-Paste is not working. Nice. Also die elementarsten
Basics-Sachen funktionieren immer noch nicht gescheit unter Wayland in mit VMWare. Ich
meine, das ist schon... Wie würde der Ami sagen? Embarrassing, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Wie kann das sein, dass so elementare Sachen wie Copy-Paste einfach noch nicht funktionieren?
Was? Artix i3, was die nicht alles haben. Ach, und die Seite sieht aber mal schon richtig
old school aus. I3. Und was... Alter, wie viele distro-Sachen es gibt. Gibt es da ein
paar Screenshots mit i3 von... Nee, das probieren wir jetzt nicht aus. Ohne System D brauche
ich nicht. Also, das könnten wir tatsächlich mal ausprobieren. Ich persönlich wäre ja
für nackiges Arch installen. Wir hauen uns einfach i3 wieder selbst drauf und gut ist.
Was wir heute mal... Wir probieren mal ein paar Sachen aus. Ich verwende ja schon seit
langer Zeit so die gleiche Config unter Linux. Also, ich habe mein GNOME-Terminal, mein ZSH,
i3 als Window-Manager und so was, i3-Gaps sogar noch. Aber es gibt ja mittlerweile jede
Menge neue Sachen, gerade für Terminals und als TMUX-Ersatz und es gibt Config-File-Manager,
Metapackage-Manager, neue PROMs, i3-Status-Anzeigen-Dinger. Ein bisschen ausprobieren, was es so Neues gibt.
Tja, das ist eines der großen Probleme, die es unter Linux gibt. Ich erinnere mal an zum
Beispiel, das ist mein Lieblingsthema, ich weiß, wenn man Hardware-Decoding machen wollte
mit Videos unter Linux. Das war eine Zeremonie von... Ich weiß nicht, seit wann Hardware-Decoding
unter Windows-Gescheit funktioniert mit GPUs. Ich sag mal 10 Jahre. Das war eine Zeremonie
von 10 Jahren unter Linux, bis das funktioniert. Die haben sich auch gestritten, ewig lange.
Lickt es am Browser, lickt es an den Grafikkartentreiber, lickt es am Linux-Kernel selbst, lickt es
an Mesa und hast du nicht gesehen, lickt es an X11, lickt es an Wayland, lickt es an
den Grafikkartenherstellern. Ohne Scheiß, die haben sich 10 Jahre rumgestritten, bis
GPU-Decoding unter Linux funktioniert hat. Und jetzt funktioniert es allerdings auch
nicht unbedingt in jeder Kombination. Du brauchst die neuesten Treiber, du brauchst das neue,
du brauchst neuere Browser, das muss die richtige Konstellation sein und dann kommt
der Hit und dann funktionieren nicht mehr alle Codecs. Also wenn du Glück hast, funktioniert
H.264, was du zu 90% brauchst, aber mittlerweile kannst du GPU-Decoding ja schon mit vielen
anderen Sachen machen, also VP8 und VP9 relativ sicher und ganz neuen Sachen. Geht teilweise
einfach gar nicht. Das ist so ein Ding, das geht unter Linux, das geht unter Windows und
wahrscheinlich Mac auch seit 10 Jahren schon oder zumindest seit 5 und unter Linux haben
sie wieder ewig gebraucht. Und einer der Dinge ist halt, weil die sich alle 5, 5 plus Jahre
streiten, wer irgendwo, irgendwann was machen muss. Nutzt du deine VM eigentlich mit mehreren
Bildschirmen? Nö. Das wurde ich gerade schon mal gefragt, ne hab ich nix. Ich hab jetzt
bis jetzt auch nicht so 100% den Vorteil verstanden. Man kann irgendwelche Sachen Snapshotten und
sowas, aber ich meine, ich betreibe das Ding eh in der VM, also kann ich auch so Snapshotten.
Gibt es keine Möglichkeit, Linux als Toolboot auszuführen mit Secureboot? Warum sollte Linux
mit Secureboot nicht funktionieren? Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich habe seit, ich übertreibe
jetzt nicht, Jahrzehnten kein Toolboot mehr gemacht. Also wann hab ich jemals zuletzt
Toolboot gemacht? Vielleicht in der Ausbildung noch oder so? Ich hab ewig kein Toolboot mehr
gemacht, aber ich würde wundern, ich meine, du kannst doch auch Linux mit Secureboot starten.
Oder ist dann das Problem, dass du, wenn du in den Boot Manager bist, kein Windows mal
starten kannst? Also ich weiß es nicht, also mich würd's wundern, wenn das nicht funktioniert
mit Secureboot. Mittlerweile ist es doch normal, dass alles Beta ist. Ist Fortnite, sogar Fortnite
ist doch immer noch Beta, oder? Das war auch so ein Ding. Das ist auch, warum ich nie empfehlen
konnte ein Media Center irgendwie so Kodi-Frontend am Fernsehen mit dem Raspberry Pi zu machen.
Genau wegen sowas war irgendein Android-TV-basiertes System schon immer überlegen. Sicherlich nicht,
was Open Source angeht und dass man versteht, was da im Hintergrund passiert. Das nicht,
aber dass die Sachen funktioniert haben. Also während du bei einem Raspberry Pi ruckelige
Kodi-Oberfläche hattest und keine Apps hattest, um Amazon oder Netflix abzuspielen, hast du
es einfach auf deinem Android-TV oder auf deinem Shield-TV, wo ja Android-TV drunter
läuft, bist einfach hin, hast die Amazon-App installiert, aufgemacht, abgespielt und es
hat funktioniert. Und wenn du Fernsehen gucken wolltest oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen
hast du dein Kodi gestartet. Also ist ja nicht so, dass ich jetzt freier Software abgeneigt
wäre. Ihr kennt mich, ich benutze ja auch tagtäglich, aber manchmal ist es tatsächlich
schwierig. Das liegt natürlich nicht zwangsläufig an den Open Source-Entwicklern, sondern oftmals
auch an den Herstellern, die keinen Bock darauf haben, das ordentlich zu supporten. Oder es
ist so ein E-Land wie beispielsweise vor allem der Support unter Wayland oder GPU-Decoding
im Browser und dann schieben sie sich gegenseitig zu den Schwarzen Peter zu, ja wer muss das
denn jetzt machen, wer könnte das jetzt und wer darf das jetzt und ich mach das auf gar
keinen Fall, dann dauert das 5 Jahre und mehr. Ja, richtig. Bootest du denn auch, also wenn
du ein BIOS Error hast, du musst, du musst EFI Zeug booten, ne, also wenn du es in der
VM machst, musst du die umstellen auf EFI, wenn du die auch mit Secure Boot laufen lassen
willst. Läuft WoW nicht mittlerweile unter Linux? Halbwegs gescheit. Also immer wenn,
das ist das Geile, das ist witzig, ne, immer wenn ich sage, ah spielen unter Linux ist
noch schwierig, kommen die ganzen Verfechter und sagen, nein nein Max, mittlerweile geht
das alles und dann sag ich dann ja, probier mal Fortnite zu spielen, probier mal Rainbow
6 zu spielen, dann sagst du, ah wer will denn so was spielen und umgedreht, wenn ich sage,
ah funktioniert das nicht, mittlerweile kommen die Leute wieder um die Ecke und sagen, nein
nein, das funktioniert nicht, das hat noch nie funktioniert, also anscheinend liege
ich ja wohl mit meiner Aussage nicht so ganz verkehrt, die ich vor einer Weile mal auch
in einem Video getroffen habe, dass vieles mittlerweile funktioniert, aber vieles genauso
gut auch nicht. Außerdem, wer braucht WoW, wenn er SuperTuxKart spielen kann? Ok, auf geht's.
So, wir legen jetzt mal eine neue VM an. Wenn ich das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht hin
bekommen sollte, weil irgendwas nicht funktioniert, dann nehmen wir einfach die Manjaro VM und
machen einen Snapshot davor, bevor wir das Zeug ausprobieren, aber ich brauche eh mal
eine neue Streaming VM. So, also Workstation 17, Premiere. Ich habe noch nie eine Workstation
17 VM angelegt, die alten Dinger sind alle, vor allem Workstation 15, 15 Profil noch.
Oh, wir brauchen was zum installieren, da habe ich hier noch nicht runtergeladen. Netboot
X, Y, Z, beste. Leute, wenn ihr öfters mal ein paar Sachen ausprobieren wollt, ich kann
euch Netboot empfehlen. Man müsste nicht immer Isos runterladen, sondern einfach nur das
Netboot ISO und dann könnt ihr davon alles starten. Ich installiere das Operating System
Later. Ihr könnt es auch gleich hier. Mein Manjaro, das läuft noch. So, Next, Linux,
wir wollen ja das ganz, ganz bestimmt. Stream heißt das Ding. Ja, Virtual Machines. Nee,
nee, nee, nee, nee. Das ist falsche, falsche Ordner. Meine VMs liegen unter Stream, VMs.
Habe ich die jetzt direkt da rein kopiert? Ich kacke, Noob. Ne, ich brauche einen extra
Ordner. Null. So, Next. Also jetzt können wir mal. Number of Processors, one number of
Cores, Leute. Acht. Wenn schon, wenn schon, kriegt ihr mal ordentlich was. Okay. Memory,
32G. Na komm, wir müssen es nicht übertreiben. 4096 mal vier, nee, mal nicht mal vier,
mal sechs. Das da. Perfekt. Das brauchen wir. 24G, Memory. Ich meine, wir haben 64G. Da
können wir auch 24G für die VM geben. Nicht, dass wir es jemals brauchen werden, aber besser
haben als brauchen. So, Bridge Network. Das da passt, das da passt. New Virtual Disk, Single
File. 256G sollte reichen. Stream, Customize Hardware, Printer raus, Accelerate 3D Graphics.
Und das da, ich glaube, das passt. Finish. Jetzt sollte das Ding hier auftaren. Und jetzt
stellen wir es noch um. Wo ist es denn? War das General? Nee, hier. UEFI. Ich glaube,
das war's. Probieren wir mal aus. Ja, ich hatte auch schon das Problem mit kein Swap
File. Das habe ich auch schon auf die Reihe gekriegt. Das ist kacke. Das ist wirklich
bitter. Dann wären random irgendwelche Prozesse gekillt. Okay. Linux Network Installs. Arch,
by the way. Aktuell ist das Arch. Auf geht's. Mittlerweile muss man ja echt sagen, ist
ein Arch Linux Installer, also ist die Arch Linux Installation wirklich einfach. Also
früher musstest du dir, mit dem kann man ja immer noch, man kann es immer noch manuell
Setup und sowas. Aber mittlerweile mit dem Installer ist das easy as fuck. Netboot heißt
das Ding. Ist nur ein paar MB groß und macht nichts anderes wie DHCP die Netzwerkkarte
konfigurieren und dann aus dem Internet quasi neuste Liste laden. Was ich vorhabe, ich will
ein paar neue Sachen ausprobieren. Und ich will mir endlich mal eine neue Streaming vorab
machen. Max, du hast mir jetzt Zeit gespart in der Ausbildung. Wieso musst du Arch Linux
Installationen machen? Wenn ja, würde ich sagen, exzellente Entscheidung von einem Ausbilder.
Jeder Admin sollte mindestens einmal in seinem Leben Arch Linux konfiguriert haben. From
scratch. Sogar Windows, Leute. Dass sie wissen, was sie verpassen. Was will denn das da oben
eigentlich von mir? Arch, by the way. Wo sieht's aus? Sag mal, wie lang brauchen das eigentlich?
Time left? Hat das irgendeinen Mirror erwischt oder was? Warum brauchen das so lang? Warum
ist das so langsam im Download? Guckt euch das mal an. Mit 4 MBit later. Hui, hui, hui.
Ja, Gentoo, Gentoo. Ich habe einen Kollegen gehabt, früher auf der Arbeit, der hat immer
Gentoo benutzt. Oder hat so teilweise so Probleme wie Fuck, der Netzwerktreiber funktioniert
nicht mehr. Fuck, der Netzwerktreiber ist nicht einkompiliert im Kernel. Ich muss jetzt
erst mal Kernel neu bauen. Oder zum Beispiel, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, er wollte
mal mit OpenOffice was aufmachen. OpenOffice. Was ist das unter Gentoo? Emerge, oder? Ist
das Emerge? Wie heißt der Package Manager von Gentoo? Ich habe nie Gentoo wirklich großartig
für mich. Ich glaube, das war Emerge. Da musstest du erst mal machen, Emerge, OpenOffice.
Und dann hat das Ding geschlagene 2 Stunden oder so kompiliert, dass er das dann graben,
seinen E-Mail-Anhang öffnen kann. Also Leute, normalerweise dauert der Download wahrscheinlich
12 Sekunden oder so und jetzt ist er ein bisschen lahm, aber was wollen wir machen? Was jetzt
übrigens gerade passiert ist, ich habe gebootet übers Netzwerk und jetzt lädt er gerade das
letzte Arch Linux, nicht wirklich ISO, aber Image runter, um es zu booten. In der Geschwindigkeit
hätte ich mir auch das offizielle ISO gezogen. Bei der Installation von Gentoo lernt man
was, das stimmt. So, gleich haben wir es. PauseChamp, Leute. Hartes PauseChamp-isieren.
Auf geht's. To release input, press Alt-Ctrl, das muss ich ausschalten. Das kann man irgendwo
in den Settings ausschalten, dass er diese doofen Meldungen da oben anzeigt. Weil es
kommt jetzt jedes Mal, guckt. Kommt jetzt jedes Mal, kommt jetzt so kacke Meldung. Okay,
wie war das? Arch install glaubt einfach, ne? Leute, Arch install, Linux Master Race, Installer
Language, Englisch 100%. Was genau sagt mir die 100% dahinter? Ach, das ist 100% übersetzt,
okay. Versteht kein Mensch, dass das damit gemeint ist, aber wenn man es weiß, ergibt
es natürlich Sinn. Okay, Keyboard Layout wollen wir haben, no dead key, Latin 1, no dead keys,
genau das. Mirror region, Germany, lokale language encoding, alles gut. Drive, ja, gibt
ja nur ein Laufwerk hier drin. This layout, select what to do with it, okay. Suggest partition
layout, x4, separate partition for home, no. Boot, 512 MB, naja, sieht doch ganz brauchbar
aus. Bootloader, Systemd, Bootctl, das ist gut. Swap, Swap lassen wir auf jeden Fall
an, Leute, ich hatte auch schon mal das Problem, keinen Swap mehr zu haben. Hostname, ich
hatsch Linux. PC Speaker ist an, MonkaS, das ist das erste, was ich ausschalten muss.
PC Speaker, da muss ich gleich weg. Root Passwort, brauchen wir nicht. User account and user,
Linux Passwort, highly secure, best practice Passwort, soll sudo user sein. Confirm and
exit, profile. Install the minimal system as well as xsoc and graphics driver. Das klingt
doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll. Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll aus, da ist x gleich
drauf, schade doch nichts. Select a graphics driver, naja. Default, das ist eine VM. Audio,
brauchen wir nicht. Kernel, lassen wir das normale Linux, kein LTS. Additional Packages,
Open SSH auf jeden Fall, aber sonst noch was, ich glaube nicht. Netzwerk-Config, Network
Manager, Timezone, wir sind in Berlin, Europe, Berlin. Optional Repositories, nope, ich glaube,
das müsste alles so passen. Ich will einen Browser, nö, will ich nicht. Wieso will
ich einen Browser? Ich hab noch nicht mal einen Window Manager. Den Vim, das ist tatsächlich
nicht verkehrt. Den Vim installieren wir, das ist immer nicht verkehrt. Können wir
aber nach der Installation auch noch machen. Trauma von Vim, warum? Vim ist das Beste,
auf dem Terminal zu editieren. Nano, null. Und Noobs verwenden Nano. Vim Master Race.
Oder, die coolen Leute verwenden mittlerweile Neo Vim. Also ich verwende Vim ja auch prinzipiell
nur noch, um kurze Sachen, also kleine Sachen auf der Commando-Seite zu editieren oder natürlich
über SSH. Also, auf dem Remod-Server Vim und das ganze dann über SSH. Das lokale Zeug,
wenn ich irgendwas entwickle, ist in der Regel Visual Studio Code bzw. irgendeine Jet-Prains-IDE.
Joe, wird das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt? Aber die coolen Leute verwenden heutzutage
e-Neo Vim. Emacs ist bei mir out. Ich habe mal eine Weile Emacs verwendet, aber ich finde
Emacs ist seit Visual Studio Code und der Erweiterbarkeit durch JavaScript, was einfach
ILS mal um hunderte Jahre voraus ist, gibt es, finde ich, nicht mehr so viele Gründe
für Emacs. Man könnte jetzt sagen, klar, für Emacs gibt es auch viele Erweiterungen
und das hat sich die letzten 20 Jahre ja auch schon voraus, was Entwicklung angeht. Wobei
man sagen muss, dadurch, dass Visual Studio Code Plugins JavaScript sind und Visual Studio
Code auch schon ein paar Jahre auf dem Buckel hat, würde ich sagen, gibt es da sogar mittlerweile
mehr und qualitativ besseres. Okay, C. H. Root in die neue Installation. Äh, ok. Was
haben wir denn für eine IP? Als erstes RM-Mod, PC-Speaker, das kriege ich Anfälle gleich,
wobei nach dem Neustart ist es wieder weg. Ok, merkt euch mal 2136. Muss ich noch irgendwas
installieren? Die Musik kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden von der Lautstärke her.
Was jetzt? Ach ja, übrigens, meine Maus wurde auf 800 DPI gesetzt. Gut Logitech hab, dass
du mir das jetzt gesagt hast, ich hätte das sonst nicht gewusst wahrscheinlich. Irgendjemand
verwendet, verwendet irgendjemand dieses bescheuerte Notification Center? Das ist das most useless
Ding in Windows. Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was man damit machen soll. Man kann den PC-Speaker
ausschalten. Ja, du kannst das Kernel-Modul entfernen für PC-Speaker. Du kannst, nee,
ich mach alle Notifications aus. Kami, danke schön für den Sub. Ich hab jetzt gar nicht
richtig geguckt. Pogger-Subscription. Disabling PC-Speaker. Genau, ja, das hier müssen wir,
das müssen wir, das müssen wir gleich machen. Ähm, warte mal, install, yay, können wir
noch machen. Yay installieren. Also mal mal Pacman minus S, shit, eine Runde shit installen,
weil ich glaube man braucht das hier für. Äh. Warum ist Paru, warum ist Paru cooler,
warte, GitHub, Paru. Aber weil's written, nee, nicht Paru, weil's written in Rust ist.
Ist wichtig, wichtig, wichtig. Okay, das heißt wir haben jetzt die Auswahl, Go, Go oder Paru.
Das wird öfters updated, das hier wird öfters updated und deswegen gewinnt das jetzt auch.
Also, nee, ich bleib einfach hier, also ich hab denn überhaupt nichts dran auszusetzen
und ob das jetzt Go oder written in Rust ist, ist mir vollkommen egal. So, install. Binary.
Nee, nee, wenn schon, wenn schon kompilieren wir selbst. Also git clone HTTPS, was war
das, ourarchlinux.com, slash, nee, org, oder? Org, slash yay.git, nee. Was muss
wir jetzt machen? Make minus SI, gell? Ja. Oh, massive. Oh nein. Man darf das ja nicht
als Root machen. Na gut. Werden wir mal mein User. Wichtig. Kommt das Video mit dem Florian?
Ja, der Florian hat grad ein paar YouTube-organisatorische Dinge zu klären, bevor wir das Video aufnehmen
können. Was hab ich denn jetzt? Ach, ich bin ja auch blöd, ich muss das erst mal rüberkoppieren.
Move. Hä? Ach so, hier. Move. Move. Alter, ich kann nicht mehr tippen. Home, Max. So.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich root, nee. Mal gucken, ob's ohne Rechte geht. Make, package. Natürlich
nicht. Natürlich nicht. chmod. Minus, nee. chown, max, max. Home, max. Ich hätt's in
der Zwischenzeit eigentlich schon mal neu runtergeladen. Ups. Nein. Na gut. Reboot.
Einmal zu viel Steuerung, D gedrückt. Reboot. Never remind me again. Disconnect CD-Laufwerk.
Mal gucken, wie schnell's bootet. Zack. Leute, ist das written in Rust? Das ist ja richtig
blazingly fast hier. Make, package. Oh. Pizzi Speaker, hau ab. Warum wir das installieren?
Warum nicht? Man kann nie oft genug Arch installieren. So, jetzt müssen wir erst mal ganz dringend
kurz mal SSH einschalten, weil ansonsten macht's laufend und dann dreh ich durch bei. Start
sshd. Und jetzt guck dir mal, das neue Windows Terminal can out of the box ssh. SSH, ich
glaub 136 ist es gewesen. Nein, natürlich nicht. Hat sich die IP geändert. Okay. 140
ist es jetzt. Alles klar. Mein DHCP-Server denkt sich auch, was ist denn da los? Max,
add. Excellent. Putty, wer verwendet denn auch Putty? Putty ist ja nur wirklich schon outdated,
schon ewig. Es gibt noch, ich weiß, unsere ganzen Windows-Admins verwenden Putty. Da
denke ich mir auch immer, Leute, seid ihr irgendwie 1990 stehen geblieben oder was?
Mobar Xterm kann man auch verwenden. Am besten einfach das neue Windows Terminal nehmen.
Eventuell mit WSL, wer das will. Warum hab ich jetzt mich eigentlich per SSH verbunden?
Was hab ich mir dabei gedacht, Chat? Irgendwas wollte ich machen. Warum hab ich dich per SSH
verbunden? Ah, ich weiß wieder. Ich wollt die Konfig für PC Speaker. You can add this
command in your ATC-Profile oder Input-AC. Input-AC wollen wir haben. Input-AC. Bell-Style-None.
Excellent. Gatschi-Buzz. So, schauen wir mal, ob der PC Speaker jetzt aus ist. Aha, PC
Speaker ist aus. Nice. Wie managst du sonst meine SSH-Sessions? Wie? Was gibt's da zu
managen? Ich hab ne Shell-History. Shell-History. Ohne File-Limit. Shell-History ist das Beste.
Da ist alles drin, was ihr braucht. Ach so, Passwörter. Ach, das meinst du. Also, eigentlich
auf 99% der VMs komm ich mit SSH-Key drauf. Und... Ich überleg grad, auf welche VM brauche
ich noch ein Passwort? Brauche ich überhaupt noch ein Passwort? Ja, auf manche Raspberry
Pi brauche ich noch ein Passwort. Und da hab ich das Default-Passwort. Das kennt jeder.
Auf neu installierte Raspberry Pi. Ansonsten ist alles... Also auch auf Cloud VMs und sowas.
Ich lass da einfach mein SSH-Key direkt eintragen. Kannste ja mittlerweile im Setup überall
machen. So, jetzt haben wir das installiert. Jetzt lass mal kurz in mich gehen. Was brauchen
wir denn jetzt noch? I3 können wir schon mal installieren. I3-WM. So, I3 geht nicht, weil
ich kein... Oh. Ach, wie haben wir den X ja schon installiert? Ich muss ja gar nichts
mehr selbst installieren. Omegalul. Was ich noch installieren soll, ist Open VM Tools.
Open VM Tools, dass wir copy-pasten können und sowas. So, sudo-e-systems-ctl-enable.
Wie heißt das? Ah! Was ist das hier? Ah, ich hab's ja nur in Input reingeschmissen.
Hm. Schon mal blöd. Ich sollte einfach das PC-Speaker-Modul unloaden und gut ist. Auf
der anderen Seite, so doof ist es gar nicht, wenn der PC-Speaker bei Root an ist. Dann
erinnert man sich immer daran, Achtung, man ist hooten. Sollte vielleicht ein bisschen
aufpassen. Vielleicht gar nicht so doof. Vielleicht lass ich... Vielleicht lass ich
es tatsächlich so. Ja, das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall. GTK-MM3. Frag mich nicht, warum,
aber ohne dieses Package funktioniert copy und paste nicht. Und warum muss ich Adobe
Source Code Pro-Fonts installieren? Was sind das für Dependencies, man? Für copy und
paste muss ich selbstverständlich Adobe Source Code Pro-Fonts installieren. Sonst funktioniert
copy-paste. Es ist ja obvious. Also wenn ich keinen Font installiert hab, dann kann ich
natürlich auch nicht copy-pasten. Logisch. Klingt nachvollziehbar. Nee, ehrlich gesagt
nicht. Aber wer weiß, der Package Manager wird's wissen. Richtig, richtig sass. So und
ich brauch jetzt meine X... Ja, das funktioniert nämlich nicht. Ganz kurz auf Wublords.files,
das brauchen wir nämlich jetzt, weil da kommen wir nicht dran vorbei. xinitrc, zack. Xinitrc,
zack. So, startX ist gut, das ist auch gut. Vmware-User ist gut. Brauchen wir alles.
Nichts. Hab ich da nicht installiert. Brauchen wir auch nicht. Ganz sicher bin, ob wir das
brauchen. Was macht denn das? Weiß ich doch jetzt, weiß ich nicht mehr. So, ich glaube,
das reicht. So, sudo minus i. Jetzt noch die Vmware-Sachen installieren. Enable. Bash-Completion,
damit der ganze Krämpel sich autocompleted. System CTL, Status, VM Tools, D ist wahrscheinlich
aus. Enable und start. So und das sollte es jetzt gewesen sein. Jetzt sollten wir eigentlich
E3 starten können, wenn ich alles richtig gemacht hab. Schauen wir mal. StartX. Easy.
Funktioniert doch. Natürlich sieht es jetzt relativ rudimentär aus, alles. Yes, generate
config, perfekt. Der Windows Key sollte der Modifier sein. Oh, ich hab kein Terminal
installiert. Da können wir doch schon gleich mal mit dem ersten Programm anfangen, was
ich ausprobieren wollte. Nämlich, ich wollte mal ein paar neue Terminals ausprobieren.
Normalerweise habe ich immer Gnome Terminal. Gnome Terminal selbst wird ja glaube ich nicht
mehr weiterentwickelt, sondern es gibt jetzt ja irgendwas Gnome Console oder sowas und
ich wollte mir schon die ganze Zeit mal einen von diesen neuen gehypten Terminals angucken.
Allerdings haben die alle irgendwas. Nein, das hat mit NVIDIA nichts zu tun. Das ist
irgendein Status-Leisten-Generator. Die ganzen neuen Terminals haben alle was, was mir auf
den Sack geht und zwar Kitty ist irgend so ein Dude, der alles hatet, was Terminal-Multiplexer
verwendet. Dementsprechend TMAX bzw. TMAX über SSH ist für'n Arsch. Nachdem ich quasi
täglich mehrfach auf unterschiedliche Kisten per SSH drauf muss und dort immer eine TMAX
Session auf hab, ist das wahrscheinlich für mich schon mal unbrauchbar. Dann gibt es
das hier, das erste Mal sich eigentlich ganz cool gelesen hat. Allerdings ist das mit
Lua-Config, MonkaS. Ich weiß nicht, warum man seinen Terminal über Lua konfigurieren
will. So, und das da? Weiß nicht. Das hab ich glaube ich noch nie ausprobiert. Nu-Shell,
ne, ich bleib bei SSH, ich hab da keinen Bedarf. Aber wir können das doch mal probieren. Wettsturm,
auf geht's. Wettsturm. Ich kann nicht starten, weil ich keinen Terminal installiert hab.
Wettsturm. Alla-Kitty ist Banger. Ist es denn, ist es denn im, okay, das gibt es auch und
Kitty gibt es das auch. Keine Nerd-Fonds. Alter, was ist denn da los? Ich glaube ich
muss doch, ich glaube ich muss doch wieder. Geht das? Weil ich wollte schon sagen, ich
glaube ich muss doch wieder zu Knomb-Terminal, weil es irgendwelche Probleme gibt. So, wie
wurde das erstmal? Wettsturm. Der Name ist schon mal geil. Okay, start, x. Bam. Okay,
das ist also Wettsturm. Die Fonds sehen schon mal ein bisschen komisch aus. Oh, ich merk
schon das erste, was mich nervt. Mittlerer Mausklick geht nicht. Mittlerer Mausklick
geht zum Copy-Pasten, nur wenn ich einmal die Sekunde drücke. Wenn ich schneller, also
Leute, wenn ich so drücke die Maustaste, klick, klick, klick, dann funktioniert's.
Wenn ich schnell einfügen will, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick,
klick, klick, klick, dann fügt er nur einmal ein. Okay, das ist schon mal cringe. Was ist
das? Warum? Ja, das ist bestimmt eine Konfig, das ist bestimmt eine Konfig-Sache. Probier
mal aus, so. Chromium. Firefox, warum sollte ich Chromins denn denn tun? Ah, wir haben
coole Icons für Passwort-Eingabe, das ist schon mal nice. Kann man nicht, was? Kann man nicht
einfach ohne irgendwelchen Soundkram installieren? Wir können das mal abbrechen. Braucht Chrom
Sound-Gedöns? Das ist, das ist Westherm jetzt. Okay, das wollen die alle. Firefox. Jack oder
Jack-Pipe-Wire. Ist mir sowas von. Ape-TTF-Font. Knu Free-Fonts. Okay, Knu Free-Fonts, die hat
wahrscheinlich Richard Stallman persönlich designt, die sehen wahrscheinlich nicht gut
aus. Warum kann ich nicht einfach, einfach mein Hack-Font installieren und gut ist? Was,
ihr sagt, ihr sagt Pipe-Wire immer. Aber ich will doch gar keinen Sound. Ich will doch
gar, ich will doch gar keinen Sound. Ich glaub, das ist irgendwie Library-Dependency. Also
meint ihr, meint ihr Pipe-Wire ist der, ist der Shit, ja? Nee, nee. Ich will einfach
nur einen fucking Browser installieren. Ich will in der V-M noch nicht mal Sound haben.
Okay, das ist okay. TTF-Droid, das sind die Android-Fonts, die sehen eigentlich ganz gut
aus. Kommt, Leute, wir machen mal Default. Wir machen, wir machen mal Default und gucken
uns mal, wie kacke es mit Knu Free-Fonts aussieht. Der hat schon mal Lieder gesungen
dazu. Oh, ich hab kein D-Menu, kann das sein? Ich hab kein D-Menu, lul. Dann nehmen wir
dann eh gleich wieder was anderes. Aber zumindest, zumindest mal starten muss ich können. Okay,
FireFox. Skip. Lärm nicht, FireFox, skip. Oh nee, please, nicht wieder der Bug, skip.
Start browsing, skip. Wenn ihr diesen komischen Bug habt, Leute, wenn ihr, wenn ihr diesen
komischen Bug habt, dass euer Browser manchmal sowas hier hat, dann kann ich euch sagen, was
ihr machen müsst. Und zwar müsst ihr in die Settings und dann Hardware Acceleration und
Hardware Acceleration ausmachen. Warum das so ist und warum das erst seit irgendwie ungefähr
in einem Jahr ein Bug ist, ich weiß es nicht. So, und das erste, was wir jetzt mal machen
ist Sponsoring Shit aus, dismiss, dismiss, dismiss, dismiss, dismiss, alles, alles dismissen
und dann ist gut. Oh nein, wir melden uns auch nicht bei Google an. So, als erstes, New
Blog Origin, korrekt. Ohne geht nichts. Nicht für, nicht für Chrome. Für FireFox. Der
Free Software Song. Oh nee, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht antun. Oh nee, das kann ich mir
jetzt nicht antun. Ok. Ein bisschen backen tut das immer noch hier, oder? Was ist das
hier? Was ist da los? Muss ich den Browser nochmal neu starten? Dass der kein Bug mehr
hat. Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Intel Grafikkarte. Nee, keine Intel Grafikkarte. Definitiv keine
Intel Grafikkarte. GameUp, danke schon für den Sub und Magri Patron 48, danke schon für
die Subscriptions. Gut, jetzt ist natürlich das Allerwichtigste. Get Emoji, get Emoji
Support. Exzellent. Da bin ich ja schon mal beruhigt, dass Emoji Support funktioniert.
Dann ist, dann ist alles gut. Und im Terminal, im Terminal geht's auch. Ja wunderbar. Dann
ist alles gut, wenn das funktioniert. Aber ich will lieber Tweet Emoji haben anstatt
die. Guck mal, das buggt auch, wenn man die falsch kopiert. Hat jemand einen Plan, was
das für ein Emoji-Font ist? Was ist denn das für ein Emoji-Font, was wir hier sehen?
Es ist, es ist nicht, es ist nicht Tweet Emoji, glaube ich. Was ist denn das? Oder ist es?
Die sind aber auch nicht richtig gerendert. Guck mal, die haben, das sind nicht Anti-Alais,
die Emojis. Control-M macht das gleiche wie Clear. Ja, aber ich schreibe trotzdem immer
Clear. Frag mich nicht, warum. Okay, aber systemweit habe ich anscheinend hier nichts
installiert, weil hier oben kann er das nicht anzeigen, richtig. Na gut. So, gut, jetzt
können wir ein paar Sachen ausprobieren. Ich würde sagen, wir haben jetzt ja Basic-Installation
ist ja am Start. So, großartig konfigurieren. Müssen wir das jetzt, müssen wir das jetzt
zum Ausprobieren nicht. Was, okay, was habe ich verpasst, Leute? Was ist es mit dieser
Zen-Frage auf sich? Ist das irgendwie neues deutsches Meme, was ich nicht kenne? Das habe
ich jetzt schon öfters gesehen. Klärt mich mal auf. Ja, aber in der VM ist es doch egal.
Wie, es ist in der VM nicht egal?
Okay, was soll meine Inter-Grafikkarte, die ich zum Ausgeben gar nicht verwende, mit dem
Rendering von meinem Browser in der VM zu tun haben? Das wird mich jetzt echt interessieren,
wie das zusammenhängen soll. Weil ausgeschlossen ist nichts, aber der Zusammenhang erschließt
sich mir nicht. Okay, wir müssen unseren Prompt hübsch machen. Als erstes müssen wir aber
nochmal in unsere E3-Konfig gehen. Okay, nach was soll ich nun? Intel Panel Refresh Linux.
What the fuck? Keine Ahnung.
So, wir gehen jetzt mal in unsere E3-Konfig und schmeißen da mal kurz ein paar Sachen
raus. Also Frontmono Space kann durchaus mal 12 sein, dass man ein bisschen was sieht und
das ist Dex. Aber Hauptsache Dex. Autostart Files, okay. So, E3-Status brauchen wir noch.
Dass wir ein bisschen was sehen. Sieht dann zwar hässlich aus, aber wir können es dann
gleich verbessern, weil wir haben ja auf unserer To-Do-Liste auch ein paar E3-Status-Ersatz-Dinger
drin stehen. Okay, nice. Jetzt haben wir zumindest schon mal ein Status-Panel. So, Netfuck-Manager.
JetBrains Toolbox brauche ich auch immer. Toolbox.
Normalerweise verwende ich den Java, please. Na gut, was willst du machen? Yes. Was hat
er jetzt für ein OpenJDK installiert? OpenJDK 19 sind wir jetzt, alles klar. Toolbox. Startet
schon mal nicht. Geht gut los. Oh fuck, doch. Startet doch. Nein, nein, nein. Accept now.
Darkseam getting started. So, anscheinend habe ich keinen Panel für solche Sachen.
Okay. Wie heißt dieses Netfuck-Manager Applet nochmal, was wir brauchen? NM, NM Applet,
Netfuck-Manager Applet. Ob das, ich glaube das brauchen wir. NM Applet. Ach doch, da
ohne ist es. Alles klar, gut. Okay, also da können wir jetzt ja anfangen mal ein bisschen
auszuprobieren. Was, was für Dinge? Also wir machen erstmal unseren Prompt hübsch, würde
ich sagen. Ich muss die, ich muss die, die Titel, die Titelleiste noch, muss die Titelleiste
gerade noch ausblenden. Ich meine, ich könnte meine alte, meine alte i3-Config natürlich
verwenden, aber das ist ja nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Titel. Wie schaltet man die
Titel aus? i3-Config, Kekel, Alter. i3-Disable-Titlebar, weg, braucht kein Mensch. Tight-Window-Titlebar,
okay. New Way to do it, Default Border Pixel, was? Default Border, alles klar, okay. Moment,
warum, warum, warum ist der wieder an? Was ist hier los? Warum ist mein PC Speaker, ach
ich hab's ja nur ins Input reingeschrieben, ich, ich däpp. Okay, Input, komm weg, jetzt
wird jetzt, wird jetzt Disabled. Arch, PC Speaker, PC Speaker, weg damit, hier. Mod,
Braub, no beep. Mod, Braub, no beep. Und dann Blacklist, PC Speaker, jaja. Zack, Reboot,
Reboot. Es ist leider einiges an Wayland nervig, ich find das ja an sich ganz gut, mein, kein
Mensch möchte mehr sich um X kümmern, aber es gibt halt viele Sachen, gerade in der VM
die nicht richtig funktionieren. Es fängt schon damit an, dass der Screen sich nicht
refresht in einer VM mit Wayland. Das ist mein Screen Refresh, richtig, richtig hartes
Legacy Feature. Er muss sagen, schnell ist das Ding hier schon, ja. Okay. Wim. Wie, das
hat er sich halt gemerkt, config, i3, i3, config, bam. Zack. Ah, yes. So ist das gut,
so mag ich das, so gefällt mir das. Jetzt sieht man nichts. So, und jetzt ist halt das
Ding, jetzt hätte ich gerne Gaps, i3 Gaps. Ich guck mal kurz, wo Blorts GitHub, wie ich
das, wie ich das mit den, mit den Gaps gemacht hab bei mir. i3, config, config, i3, config,
Gap. Oh, Window Class, Pixel. i3 Gap Merge, vielleicht haben die was in ihrem Pull Request
drinstehen. Pull Request. Hat i3 nicht irgendwie eine gescheite Dokument auf ihrer Seite gehabt?
Gaps, Docs, nach was soll ich, User Guide, Gaps. So, das geht erst, since version oder
signs, since, ja, since version 4.22 und guck mal, was wir haben. Wir haben version 4.22,
richtig Pleading Edge Features. Gaps Inner 5. Haben wir jetzt Gaps? Wir haben Gaps. Perfekt.
Exzellente Gaps. Wir haben halt kein Background. Ohne Background sackt natürlich ein bisschen.
Guck mal, wie Wim das schon mal nicht checkt. Was, Smart Gaps. Only enable outer Gaps, when
there is exactly one Window or Split Container Workspace. Ah ja, das heißt die outer Gaps
gehen weg, sobald ich zwei aufmache. Vielleicht gar nicht so blöde. Zumindest ich will, ich
will das blaue um das Fenster nicht mehr haben. Das soll weg. Kann das sein, dass Border Pixel
Null, dass das eigentliche ist, was ich brauche. Die Fall Border Null. Kann ich nicht einfach
Null sagen? Easy. Geht doch auch. So, wunderbar. So, ich brauche, ich brauche irgendein Background,
sonst. Was nehmen wir für einen Background? Das ist jetzt West-Türm, das wollte ich heute
mal ausprobieren. Bis jetzt gibt es schon ein paar Sachen, die gehen mir auf den Keks
an. Bild des Tages. Ich habe mein Bild des Tages Skript hier noch nicht drauf. Wie setze
ich das denn hier? Bild des Tages. Get Wallpaper. Ich brauche ein ordentliches Hacker. Moment,
warum habe ich denn jetzt immer noch... Leute, warum ist denn da jetzt immer noch eine Titelleiste?
Muss ich das dazu erstmal schließen? Ach ja, ich muss das einmal zumachen. Jetzt haben
wir auch keine Titelleiste mehr. White Papo Happy. Das ist gut. Das machen wir jetzt,
das finde ich gut. Sehr guter Background. Kann das sein, dass das nicht die richtige...
Gibt es das auch in 4K? Copy Link Address. Was ist denn das für eine... Was ist denn
das für eine Resolution, man? Das ist ja nix. Egal, den nehmen wir jetzt trotzdem. Safe Image
erst. White BG. Excellent. Downloads. BG. White BG. Excellent. Der hat was. Den lassen
wir jetzt so hier. Der müsste allerdings nochmal ein bisschen upscaled werden. Ich
muss ehrlich sagen, das ist ja so pixelig wie unter Windows XP. AI Upscaling. Okay. Was
ist denn da eine gute Seite? Big JPEG. AI Super Resolution. Lossless Image Enlarger.
Nur andere Enlarger. Spam Mails. Home Downloads. Hallo? Willst du das da hinschieben? White
BG. Start. Upscaling. Vierfach. Noise Reduction. Da muss nix redacted werden. Ja, Leute, ist
das ein Artwork oder ist das ein Foto? Was ist das jetzt so wirklich? Es ist ein Foto
mit einem Artwork drin. Ich kann mir sagen, was ist ein Foto? Okay, probieren wir das
andere auch nochmal aus. Smart PNG. Upscaling. Track and Drop. Downloads. White BG. 400%.
Start. Download. Okay. Ist das jetzt schöner? Ich weiß nicht, was das hier für ein Image
Viewer ist. Leute, was ist das für ein Image Viewer? Der sieht irgendwie broken aus. Vergleichen
wir das gleich mal. Downloads. Not bad. Leute. Not bad. Nicht schlecht. Nicht schlecht AI
Upscaled hier. Nicht schlecht. Man sieht schon, dass er sich ein paar Sachen hinzu erfunden
hat zu dem Bild. Ja. Nicht schlecht. Nicht schlecht. Safe Image S. Okay. Wir vergleichen
die Bilder mal kurz. Chrome. Ich hab leider nix anderes als Image Viewer als Firefox
gerade. Okay. Das ist das Originalbild. Hauptsächlich, hauptsächlich Weichzeichner. Hauptsächlich
der Weichzeichner, der hier ein bisschen problem. Also ich muss sagen, das hier ist näher,
das ist näher am Original dran. Dafür ist hier der Pepo deutlich schärfer. Also hier
ist der Pepo schärfer und hier ist es überschärfer Pepo. Guck mal. Hier ist es weicher und dafür
ist es halt, also das ist auf jeden Fall mehr am Original dran, aber das ist weicher und
der Pepo ist schärfer. Was sagt ihr Leute? Welches taugt mehr? So instinktiv sagt man
eigentlich das überschärfte, aber ich glaube so das mit dem Weichgezeichnen ist gar nicht
so schlecht. Ja. Ja das erste denke ich auch. Hier das da. CP. Also das da. WhiteBG. Kopieren
wir das drüber. Und schon haben wir einen scharfen Pepo im Background.
Yep. Jetzt haben wir eigentlich unser Ziel für heute schon erreicht. Jetzt können wir
weggehen. AI Upscale in Pepo haben wir am Start. Nice. Sehr schön. Downloads, WhiteBG,
das muss ich in meinen Startup Skript reinhauen. Also Vesturm gefällt mir nicht, auch vom
Copy Paste und Mouse Handling. Das muss man glaube ich ziemlich, Captain Peng, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Das muss man glaube ich ziemlich customisieren, dass das taugt. Okay wir probieren
jetzt mal eine Sache aus. Ich Reboot jetzt mal. Jaja. Und dann gucken wir mal ob der
Automat, ah ich habe noch was vergessen. Ich noob. Ich habe automatisches X starten
vergessen. Ich habe es schon wieder gelöscht, das Original. Vielleicht können wir es noch
ausprobieren. Das andere auf Artwork zu stellen. Weil irgendjemand gefragt hat wie ich das
mache mit automatischem X starten. Ich habe dazu in meinem Profil, meinem Shell Profil
etwas drin stehen, dass man nicht mal Start X eintippen muss. Und? Und? Background please?
Was ist denn hier dran verkehrt? Sleep 2? Vor allem bei User? Achso BG Phil. Ich noob,
ich sollte vielleicht noch angeben. Was? Downloads? Hat ich das nicht eben kopiert?
Wie heißt das Ding? Downloads, White, White, BG, JPEG. Ah, ah, Postchamp, Postchamp.
Ah, da sind wir. Jetzt wird es automatisch gesetzt. Nice. White, Peppo, Happy. Also
wie ich das mache, wie ich das mache, dass ich automatisch neu, äh, dass ich automatisch
beim Einloggen den X Server starte, da habe ich mal irgendwann Arch, Autostart X. Da habe
ich mal was hier aus dem Arch, aus dem Archwigi kopiert. Autostart X, genau das da. Äh,
Bash Profile. Also man kann es auch, man kann es auch in sein ZZZSH Profile machen. So und
jetzt pass mal auf. Jetzt ich reboot nochmal und dann logge ich mich ein. Dann werdet ihr
sehen, sobald ich mich einlogge, also man braucht gar keinen, gar keinen Login Manager
oder sowas, wenn man nur einen Desktop haben will, mit einem User. Ja, ansonsten ist natürlich
schon sinnvoll. Guck, einloggen, bam, start automatisch X. Und das Gute ist, ich kann
immer noch jetzt beispielsweise hier auf einen anderen Desktop switchen. Äh, nicht Desktop,
auf ein anderes, auf eine andere Konsole switchen. Wenn ich mich da einlogge, dann startet nicht
X. Also genauso wie es, genauso wie es sein soll. Login Manager ist bloated. Außerdem
haben wir jetzt das beste, das beste Desktop Hintergrund. Exzellent, exzellent, so mache
ich das. So, Firefox. Wie war das jetzt mit Smart Gaps? Wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Smart Gaps. Smart Gaps on. Weißt du, das ist eigentlich nicht das, was wir machen wollen,
aber man kann es ja mal ausprobieren. Smart Gaps on. Ah, Moment, die Smart Gaps sind
nur da, wenn es mehr als eine Anwendung gibt. Hm. Hm. Äh. Nee. Was haben wir sonst noch
da? Inverse Outer. Hä? Nee, nee, nee. Aber man kann sagen, Outer Zero? Nee. Gaps. Was
ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied dazwischen? Ups. Kein Unterschied. Dann lassen wir das
jetzt einfach so. Da kann ich, da kann ich, da kann ich mit leben. Alles klar. Also Vestorm
hat mich jetzt instant nicht sonderlich angesprochen. Also ich meine, ich habe nichts von den Features
bisher ausprobiert. Also das Copy Paste ist sehr, sehr, sehr dräge. Ja, weiß nicht.
Erstmal ordentlichen Shell installieren. Zisch. Eine Runde zisch. Moin, was? Guten Morgen,
meine Freunde. Kannst du mal kurz über die Teile schauen? Sollte alles passen? Bestehen
und blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub. Äh. 2080 wird behalten, weil Preise kann ich
machen. Äh. Ach so, hier. So. Also es ist nicht, als hätte ich wahnsinnig großartig
einen Plan davon. Also meinen neuesten PC habe ich einfach so zusammengestellt, indem
ich mir in allen Bereichen das Beste gekauft habe und gut ist. Würde ich aber nicht unbedingt
empfehlen. So, E5 13600K Prozessor. Also wenn ich, wenn ich die Videos auf YouTube richtig
verfolgt habe, ist der glaube ich ganz gut für Gaming. Das dürfte so für Gaming der
beste Preis Leistung CPU technisch sein. Ja, Tillix habe ich mir auch aufgeschrieben,
kann man ausprobieren. So, Mainboard. Wo sehe ich jetzt, was du ausgewe... Hä? Okay.
Ist der alternate, ist alternate ding irgendwie broken oder? Ach, das ist nur der Konfigurator.
Ja, dann hast du den falschen Link geschickt. Funktioniert nämlich nicht. Funktioniert
nämlich nicht. Man kann auch nicht mit Maustaste, das finde ich, okay, das ist auch blöde.
Ah doch, ne, das geht mit... Okay, das Terminal ist bugged, das kann man nicht verwenden.
Also wenn, wenn font resize schon nicht richtig funktioniert, aber wenn man ein zweites Terminal
aufmacht, dann geht's wieder. Boah, ne, das weiß ich jetzt schon, dass mich das abfacken
wird. Das, das wird mich, das wird mich richtig nerven. Okay, ne, das können wir nicht nehmen.
Das war font resize, ja. Font resize bugged, ne, ne, das können wir nicht nehmen, das halte
ich denn aus. Vesturm, sorry, Vesturm, weg. Vesturm aus Vestamp uninstall, das ist auch
Sixhead-Time. Okay, was probieren wir als nächstes aus? Also, was ich gerne hätte,
ich weiß, das wurde oft empfohlen. Hat das, hat das so ein T-Max, T-Max-Style, Tiling,
oder nicht? Ne? Weil ich fand die Idee dahinter, also warum ich, warum ich überhaupt nach den
anderen Alternativen geguckt hab, ich war, ich bin der ganzen Sache gar nicht so abgeneigt
gewesen, lokal kein T-Max zu verwenden, nur Remote. Das hat, das hat ja mehrere Vorteile.
Ich mein, T-Max lokal ist halt ein bisschen doof. Zum Beispiel, wenn du mal ein bisschen
was längeres copypasten musst und solche Geschichten, dann musst du erst das eine Teil
in Fullscreen machen und dann hin und her, und dann kannst du nicht gescheit vorn zurückscrollen
und sowas. Das ist, das ist nicht, das ist nicht so schön. Ich mein, klar, man könnte
jetzt sagen, ich hab, ich hab ja einen Tiling-Window-Manager, also sprich, warum brauche ich überhaupt,
warum brauche ich überhaupt einen Tiling-Terminal? Ich sag euch ganz ehrlich, ich mag das eigentlich,
wenn das Tiling im Terminal ist. Ansonsten kann ich nämlich einfach wieder Gnome-Terminal
verwenden und gut ist. Also was gibt es als Alternative noch? T-Links gibt es da noch,
wie ist das glaube ich? Terminator ist so der Klassiker. Kitty wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren,
wobei, nee, Kitty werde ich nicht verwenden, weil das Probleme hat mit SSH, T-Max über
SSH, weil es da irgendwie Probleme mit Escape-Sequenzen gibt und ich verwende T-Max über SSH sehr
oft. Und wenn das nicht funktioniert und manchmal Probleme macht, kann ich das, kann ich das
nicht gebrauchen. Dann gab es das hier noch. Okay, yes. T-Links muss aber auf die eigene
Seite. Okay, was haben wir alle, Kitty? Okay, das kommt schon mal mit einem, die Font-Selection,
das hat ja auch kein ordentliches Menü, das Copy-Pasten funktioniert zumindest schon mal
ein bisschen besser. So, also die Standard-Font-Auswahl ist cringe, wie konfiguriert man das? Config,
hier aller Kitty-Jimmel, Rust-FMT-Tommel, ja welche ist denn jetzt die richtige? Ey,
ich probiere ein paar Linux-Programme aus, unter anderem neue Terminals, also die Default-Config
hat einen ganz grausamen Font. Dark-Reader, erstmal das allerwichtigste installieren.
The Dark-Reader, yes. Schon viel, viel besser, yes. Also die GNU-Fonts sind mir ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen zu, bisschen zu small. Font. Ja, ich mache eine neue Arch, wir haben eine
neue Arch-Installation, ja. Pin? Pin? Ich kann das Firefox mittlerweile out of the box,
dann erzähl mal. Erzähl mal, wie mache ich das? Probier mal das aus, Manage, aus, so.
Und jetzt? Einstellungen, Settings wahrscheinlich, oder? Settings? Nee, so? Nee. Achso, man muss
einfach, das braucht ein bisschen. Achja, nö, dann brauchen wir gar keinen Dark-Reader
mehr. Weg, weg damit, Extensions, bam. Verbandt direkt wieder. Also solange es funktioniert,
soll mir das recht sein. Ach, die Webseite muss das unterstützen, ich bin mal gespannt,
ob die Webseite das nicht unterstützt. Wahrscheinlich, okay, heise, heise kann das bestimmt nicht.
Nee, obviously, was sonst, ja? Logisch. IT-New-Site, aber Darkseam ist nicht, ist out of scope.
Ich will einfach nur mal die, die, okay. Wo muss das hin? Home, config. Okay, wir kopieren
uns mal, wir kopieren uns mal die Beispiel, wobei wir können die einfach runterladen.
Config, weil so sieht das, so sieht das ziemlich kacke aus. W-Get, was? Null. Oder wie die
Amis sagen, W-Get, ich hätte mich da nie dran gewöhnen können, dass was W heißt.
So, haben wir das jetzt richtig? Archvicky kann das auch nicht mit Darkseam, dann muss
er doch wieder Darkreader installieren. Wo ist die Musik? Okay, also, jetzt haben wir
den Cramp hier. Wim, schauen wir mal, font, weil der font ist schon mal gar nichts. Ich
muss, Moment, Moment, Sekunde. Hack, TTF, ich muss erstmal meinen Lieblingsfont installieren.
Jetzt, gut. Also, font. Muss, muss es wirklich Jammel sein, ja? Hack. Klein oder groß, wenn
ich klein? Style Regular, soll mir recht sein. Okay, jetzt zumachen und wie, was? Okay, okay.
Das war das falsche, was ich offen hab. Das ist jetzt Hackfont? Ja, das ist Hackfont, nice.
Funktioniert schon mal. Jetzt natürlich bloß die Frage. Reicht das, kann man das reloaden?
Reload, Konfig, muss man das ohne es zu schließen? Apply, Konfig, on the fly. Live Reload gibt
es. Live Reload. Aha. Live Reload. Live Reload. True. True Lulvee. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt
da reingehe und sag Hack und geb da irgendeinen Müll ein, dann ist es broken. Okay. Live
Reload, das ist ein nicees Feature. Das finde ich, das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir gut.
Wo gebe ich denn die Font Size ein oder muss ich einfach so? Nee. Also, ich meine, wenn
er sich das merkt, soll mir das Recht sein? Merkt er sich das? Nee, natürlich nicht.
Alter, ich kann ja tippen. Wo kann man jetzt hier die Font Size eingeben? Oder muss man
einfach das dahinter schreiben? Nee. Size? Ach, da unten. Size? 18, ne? Oh. Ah, busy
fat vielleicht. 16, 14. Alter, geh mal fort. Ist ja nervig. Das finde ich eigentlich schonmal
ganz okay. Ja. Ach ja, da kann ich, da kann ich mit leben. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz
nice. Gut, ich meine, man muss jetzt halt TMAX verwenden für Multiplexing Zeug, aber man
vermahre ich die ganze Zeit jetzt ja auch schon. Also ist nicht so wild. Ich hab gelesen, es
gibt jetzt einen TMAX Fork. TMAX Fork mit Image Support. Irgendwie TMAX Snacks oder
irgendwie sowas? Nee. Slicks? Oh, wie heißt der Kram? Slacks? Ich kann mir das nicht
merken. Image Support. Da kann man jetzt Bilder anzeigen. Sixel. Sixelsupport. Wer soll
sich das alles merken? Wer soll sich, wer soll sich das, wer soll sich das alles merken?
Ja. Sixel, Sixel heißt das. Kann man jetzt in TMAX Images anzeigen. Das ist ganz wichtig,
Anime Gifts. Hab ich, hab ich noch nicht ausgebildet. Gibt's da kein Arch-Package? Gibt's da kein
Arch-Auer? Doch. Lip-Sixel-Git. Okay. Okay. Und jetzt Downloads. Downloads. Downloads.
Right-BG. Funktioniert nicht. Und unterstützt das, unterstützt das das Terminal nicht?
Kann das sein? Aha. Das kann das nicht. So, so. Das kann das nicht.
Schon wieder was? Ich glaube, ich bleib, ich glaube, ich bleib wahrscheinlich, kann es,
kann es glauben, Terminal? Ah, wie Sixel jetzt. Diese Webseiten, Mann. Diese Webseiten, Alter.
Das Problem ist, wenn ich Kitty verwende, Kitty spackt wohl rum mit TMAX über SSH und
das brauche ich regelmäßig. Und es ist auch keine Option, irgendwie was anderes da zu
verwenden. TMAX ist gerade bei uns auf der Arbeit total verbreitet, um auch zusammen
sich was anzugucken auf dem Server. Oder wenn du was länger laufen lassen hast und sowas.
Was ist FUT? Wie viele Terminal Emulator gibt's denn hier eigentlich? FUT. Codeberg.org.
Klingt ja auch schon wieder ganz, ganz furchtbar. Toll. Drei Jahre. Three years ago. Na geil.
FUT. Vor vier Tagen jetzt. Teachers. Wayland Native. Oh, das heißt, ich kann das nicht
ausführen unter X. Sehe ich das richtig? Geht das? Minimalistic Wayland Terminal Emulator.
Okay, wenn das kann ich nicht starten. FUT. Bam. Goodbye. Er ist zumindest nett. Das wird
schon mal nix. Okay, was ist hier supported? Kitty ist unsupported. Reasoning. Oder flamet
der Kitty-Autor bestimmt wieder rum. Aber Kitty hat irgendwie so ein Native-Programm
zum Images anzeigen. Alter, manchmal ist so das Linux Ökosystem so ein bisschen Clusterfuck,
oder? Okay, Westerm kann das angeblich. Okay, vielleicht geben wir Westerm dort nochmal
eine Chance, wenn es ihren komischen Resize-Issue hinbekommt. Westerm. Okay, das kann das Image
too. Downloads. WhiteBG. Aha. Aber das Resize ist nicht richtig. Aber es ist schon cool,
oder? Es hat schon was, das im Terminal zu haben. Irgendwie ist es nice. But why? Warum
nicht? Kitty kann das wohl mit dem eigenen Programm. Ja, ja, das habe ich auch schon
gesehen. Kann es das an die Größe anpassen, vielleicht hier? Moment, das kann GIFs anzeigen.
Moment. GIFs im Terminal. Seriously. Moment, das müssen wir jetzt ausbrieren. Aja, ja.
Ne, ne. Wunderbar. Was das brauchen wir jetzt? Save As. Okay. Downloads. Aja, ja. Excited.
Anime Excited GIF. Leute, im Terminal. Ich fasse es nicht. Eigentlich eine ganz coole
Sache. Eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache. Ich fand... Nicht, dass man das jetzt wirklich
brauchen würde, ja? Loop Mode. Aber das kann man sogar. Komm, man kann sogar sagen Loop.
Minus L. Force war das. Ne, was war das? Minus L. Loop. Hab ich schon wieder. Loop Mode.
Auto Force Disabled. Die habe ich doch richtig gemacht. Aber das Loopen ist kaputt. Guckt,
das fängt nicht mehr von vorne an. Es ist broken. Es loopt nur einmal. Was machst du
noch mal beruflich? Ich bin bald Senior Linux Engineer ab 1. April. Aktuell bin ich noch...
Ist eigentlich scheißegal. Die Aufgaben unterscheiden sich gar nicht so großartig. Aber das funktioniert
nicht. Ganz wichtig. Also heute haben wir schon mal eins gelernt. Animierte GIFs im Terminal.
Kann es denn? Kann es denn? Tealix? Moment. Image Tool. Das kann es wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil Gnome Terminal das auch nicht kann. Ne, kann das nicht. Okay, also wer kann es denn?
Wer kann das denn? Allerkritik kann es nicht. Konemo kann es nicht. Kontur kann es. Ich
weiß nicht mal, was Kontur überhaupt ist. Kontur Terminal. Modern C... Muss das jetzt
wirklich sein? Modern C++ Terminal Emulator. Kontur. Das ist gar nicht mal so doof. Es
macht aber kein Tiling und sowas. Buffer Offerflip Terminal. Okay, Features. GPU Accelerated Rendering
von Ligature Support. Ne, brauch ich nicht. Emoji Support. Crufeme Cluster Support. Was?
Crufeme Cluster Support. Also soweit ich weiß, ist ein... Weil das ist Unicode Speak. Das
ist glaube ich das Character, was aus mehreren Unicode Bites am Ende zusammengesetzt wird.
Also der... Das... Ich hab da mal ein Video zu aufgenommen. Da hab ich das erklärt. Ich
hab's aber schon wieder vergessen. Was diese unterschiedlichen Dinger waren. Von... Beim
Encoding. Color Schemes Profiles. Synchronized Rendering Text Reflow. Okay, was ist das?
Kontur. Kontur. Okay. Das ist noch zur Nische. Cute Sex Multimedia FFmpeg. Vulcan Headers.
Ja, jetzt übertreib halt mal. Das ist ja richtig Blazingly Fast. Vulcan. Yes. Das muss ich
erstmal selbst kompilieren noch. Jetzt kommt gleich ganz ekliges CMake Output. Ah yes.
Einfach Terminal selbst kompilieren.
Wir müssen auch gleich Emoji Support ausprobieren.
Alter, was hat's mit diesem Senfkram auf sich? Wie ausgelastet ist denn der Rech... Das ist
ja ätzend hier. Das muss ich wieder uninstallen. Kein H-Top drauf, Cringe. H-Top. Wobei die
coolen Leute ja nicht mal mal H-Top verwenden, sondern... Wie heißt dieses andere B-S-T-T-O-P?
Kann sein. Ja, das da, genau. Die coolen Leute verwenden ja das. Wobei ich ganz ehrlich,
ich muss sagen, das ist mir schon fast zu viel. Das ist mir schon fast zu viel. Ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen, ich bin da mit H-Top eigentlich ganz zufrieden. Das ist mir fast schon ein
bisschen zu viel, das Guten hier. Okay, wie heißt das denn? Contour. Aha. Hat schon mal
ein ganz komisches... Wie konfiguriert man das? Config? Muss man bestimmt neu... Run-Time-Configuration.
Okay, okay. Und wo ist das Config-File? Flatpak? Haben die einen Config-Example vielleicht
mal irgendwo? Leute, warte mal. Alter, Examples. Wie sieht denn so ein Config aus, man? Scheint
nicht im Scope gewesen zu sein, das da hinzuschreiben. Wie sieht denn ein Config... Run-Time-Config-Reload?
Im Wiki, das kann sein. Guck mal mal. Contour-Config, ist es das? Nee, oder? Das ist was anderes.
Bild vor Kubernetes, ja. Ganz genau. Okay, alles... Con? Es ist gecrashed. Es ist gecrashed,
weil ich Tapp-Tapp gedrückt habe. Ich fasse es nicht. Okay, das werde ich nicht verwenden.
Ist das schlecht? Das crasht, wenn ich Tapp-Tapp drücke. Alter, ist das schlecht? Oh Mann.
Mal gucken, was das für eine Fehlermeldung schmeißt. Bam, Segmentation-Fault. Kackel,
Alter. Okay, das kommt mal gleich wieder runter. Was ist denn... Was ist Confuse, Mann? Was
ist Confuse? Hab ich anscheinend installiert. C-Library for Passing, alles klar. Contour-Shit.
Okay, das... Sorry, ein Terminal, was crasht, wenn ich Tapp-Tapp drücke, kann ich wirklich
nicht benutzen. Oh Mann, Alter. Richte mir gerade einen Heim-Server mit Proxmox, mit
einer Debian-VM, mit Next-Log, ein paar Tipps oder Must-Have-Terminal-Tools. H-Top. Git,
H-Top, T-Mags. D-Stats. Ein paar Sachen, um halt Informationen um das System rauszukriegen.
Ansonsten benutzt du das ja eh nicht. Außer Remont dich drauf zu connecten. Okay, das ist
schon mal nix. Weil es kein Audiodevice gefunden hat. Also seriously, wenn ein Terminal crasht,
weil es kein Audiodevice gefunden hat, dann ist wirklich irgendwas ein bisschen verkehrt.
Ich würde erwarten, dass ein Terminal ohne Audiodevice funktioniert. Das ist so modern
und Pleading Edge, das hat doch keiner ausprobiert. Jetzt hab ich den Emoji-Support, jetzt hab
ich's aninstalliert, hab den Emoji-Support gar nicht ausprobiert. Aber egal, ein Terminal,
was crasht, kann ich wirklich nicht gebrauchen. By the way, kann man das installieren via
Flatpak. Okay, nee, Flatpak müssen wir jetzt nicht anrufen. Okay, Boot hat schon mal nicht
funktioniert, weil... Nee, nicht Boot. Foot hat schon mal nicht funktioniert, weil Wayland
only. Alles klar. Okay, aller Kritiker kann keinen Terminal... Wie sieht das eigentlich
mit Emojis aus? Achso, okay, ach, das hat nicht Bild, ich brauche einen Emoji-Font.
Okay, das heißt... Okay, dann brauch ich Twi-Moji. Twi-Moji. Twi-Moji... Hallo. Nee,
was ist denn jetzt das Richtige? TTF Twi-Moji oder TTF Twi-Moji? Was ist denn jetzt hier
der Unterschied zwischen den Packages? Ich mag das nicht, dass es kein Rechts-Click-Menü
hat. Ich kopiere... Ohne Mist, Leute, ich kopiere unglaublich gern mit der rechten Maustaste.
Wir haben zwei Packages. Dass da Out of Date dran steht, das hat oftmals nicht viel zu
sagen. Aha. Oh nein, jetzt bewegen wir uns im Territorium. Wie werden Emojis
gespeichert? Da habe ich mal ein Video darüber gemacht. Es gibt vier verschiedene Standards,
wie Emojis gespeichert werden können in Fonts. Es gibt was von Microsoft, es gibt was von
Adobe, es gibt was von Mozilla und es gibt was von Apple. Und C-B-D-T-Z-B-L-Z? Ist glaube
ich das von Adobe? Nee, von Microsoft, von Microsoft. Jetzt ist die Frage, was aller
Emojifontformat braucht. Was braucht das denn? SVG, oder? Wir müssen Support für SVG haben.
What the fuck? Alles klar. Okay, wir probieren uns jetzt einfach mal aus, ob es dann funktioniert,
wenn ich jetzt das da installiere. Okay, if you have other emoji fonts installed but wasn't
too emoji. Ah, Emojis. Okay, das benutzt gleich mal Emojis und das nicht. Das muss ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich restarten, dass es das checkt. Aha, Emoji am Start. Mit dem Unterschied,
den Escape, den da kann er nicht. Den kann er nicht? Der Terminal Emulator kann ihn allerdings.
Zu geil, Alter. Leute, das ist der Wahnsinn. Ohne Scheiß, Unicode Emojis, Terminal Renderdinger,
es ist absoluter Wahnsinn. Es ist so ein Minenfeld, das ganze Ding. Alles klar. Dieses Emoji geht
hier nicht. Dieses Emoji geht hier aber. Das scheint sich ja um das hier zu handeln, oder?
Nee, es scheint sich um das hier zu handeln. Das hier, okay. Das da geht in VTE-basierten
Terminals. Das geht allerdings hier in aller Kritik nicht. Warum? Man weiß es nicht. Was
haben wir? Okay, voll. Minus R, Twee Emoji. Hallo? Ach nee, TTF. TTF, Twee Emoji. So,
entfernen wir das mal und installieren das andere Twee Emoji Color. Emoji One gibt es
auch noch, wobei ich sagen muss, Emoji One ist ja JoyPixels und die neuen JoyPixels gefallen
mir nicht mehr. Die alten JoyPixels basierten, glaube ich, auf den Mozilla Emojis. Mozilla
hat ja eigene und die alten, als JoyPixels noch Emoji One war, basierte das auf den,
man sieht ein bisschen die Ähnlichkeiten vielleicht noch. Basierten quasi die Mozilla
Emojis auf, nein, die ersten Emoji Emojis basierten auf den Mozilla Emojis, jetzt haben
sie die irgendwie weiterentwickelt. Was auch immer. Und die neuen gefallen mir nicht
mehr. Die hier finde ich nice oder Twee Emojis. Okay, also jetzt probieren wir Emoji Color.
Das ist nicht so einfach, einfach hier mal ein paar Emojis zu copypasten und es funktioniert
immer, ihr seid hier immer noch unter Linux unterwegs. Ist das nicht so? Okay, mit diesem
Emoji-Font kommt das schon mal gar nicht klar. SVG. Refresh-Fontcache.
Oder? Ist nicht so einfach. Warum macht man das eigentlich doppelt? Das ist doch useless.
Jetzt muss ich das andere deinstallieren. Okay, Emojis, please. Okay, mit dem Emoji-Font
funktioniert's nicht, mit dem anderen funktioniert's. Das macht mich fertig, Leute, das ist so weird.
Geil. Okay, wunderbar. Also man muss sagen, das ist anscheinend ein Riesending. SVG in
... Also das unterstützt a la Kriti anscheinend nicht, das andere Format unterstützen sie.
Okay, also immer, ich geb's jetzt auf. Was war das andere, was ich noch aus... Also
Westurm kann es ja anscheinend von Hause aus, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab. Die können
ja anscheinend von Haus aus Emojis. Außer dass das aus irgendwelchen Gründen Schmoll Emojied.
Emojis sind nicht zwei Zeichen, sondern das ist richtig. Jaja, das ist sehr, sehr weirdchamp.
Ich hab da mal ein Video zugemacht, wie sich das verhält. Also du hast... Ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das noch aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege. Also du hast einmal den
Unicode-Standard. Der Unicode-Standard legt, ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht immer, wie das
genau heißt, aber einfach gesagt, nehmen die Zeichen in diesen Standard auf und geben
denen verschiedene IDs. Dann gibt es Implementierungen von Unicode beziehungsweise Encoding, sowas
wie UTF-8 oder UTF-16 oder UTF-32. Das ist die Frage, wie Unicode quasi repräsentiert
wird. UTF-8 ist folgendermaßen, also UTF-8 ist so der, so mit der verbreitetste aktuell
unter.NET ist es tatsächlich noch UTF-16, aber UTF-8 ist so das verbreitetste. UTF-8
ist ein nicer Hack, weil UTF-8 verwendet zum Encoding von Zeichen mehrere Bites und anhand
der letzten vier Bits, glaube ich, ich glaube anhand der letzten vier Bits pro Byte entscheidet
UTF-8, ob das nächste Byte noch zum Zeichen dazugehört oder nicht. Was dazu führt, dass
UTF-8 abwärts kompatibel zu Ascii ist. Ascii braucht die unteren 128, glaube ich, die 128
Zeichen und die sind identisch bei UTF-8 mit Ascii. Und anhand der letzten vier Bits entscheidet
UTF-8 dann, ob es weitergeht. Zum Beispiel ein Emoji besteht in UTF-8 aus vier Bytes
und jeweils sind die letzten Bits auf 1 gesetzt, damit der Decoder weiß, dass es noch ein
weiteres Byte gibt. Es gibt das erste Byte, da steht drinnen, es kommt noch ein zweites
Byte, da steht drinnen, es kommt noch ein drittes Byte, im dritten Byte, jetzt kommt
noch ein viertes Byte und im vierten Byte steht nicht mehr drinnen, es kommt noch ein
fünftes Byte. Das heißt, dann weiß der Decoder, aha, das ist ein vier Byte Zeichen im Endeffekt
und daran kann es dann erkennen, welches Unicode Zeichen das Ganze eigentlich repräsentiert.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch, dann gibt es noch irgendwie was, ein Code-Point ist, glaube
ich, das, was Unicode festlegt, dann gibt es noch ein Crefim und ein Crefim ist, glaube
ich, das, was als logischer Character gilt. Also du hast zum Beispiel irgendwelche Sonderzeichen,
die im Terminal allerdings, wenn du weiter drückst, ein Zeichen sein soll. Das ist dann,
glaube ich, ein Crefim und das Ganze muss dann wiederum von deinem, von deinem Font-Renderer
umgesetzt werden in, wie sieht das in der jeweiligen Schriftart aus? Und in der Schriftart
hast du dann verschiedene, verschiedene, oder was da Crefims, ich weiß es nicht mehr,
so in deiner Schriftart hast du dann verschiedene Zeichen, die man mappen kann auf das, was
Unicode definiert hat und der Font-Renderer entscheidet dann wieder halt dieses Unicode-Zeichen
in dieser jeweiligen Schrift dann aussieht. Und der Witz ist, um so den Emoji zu rendern,
kommt noch, noch eine weitere Sache dazu. Wie speichert der Font die Emoji-Farb da, also
wie speichert er die Bilder? Und da gibt es, da gibt es verschiedene Standards, es gibt
SVG in OT, es gibt CB-Dingsbums. Ja, Color Emoji Standards. Da gibt, da gibt es, da gibt
es drei verschiedene. Es gibt Apple, es gibt Adobe, es gibt Microsoft, es gibt Mozilla.
Das muss auch nicht zwangsläufig Emojis sein. Moment, wenn schon muss ich euch das jetzt
richtig, ja, hinter muss ich euch das jetzt richtig zeigen. Also, es gibt, ja, es gibt
SVG, das zu speichern, es gibt, ich glaube SVG macht glaube ich Apple, dann gibt es Microsoft,
das da, dann gibt es Googles, das da und dann gibt es noch Mozilla. Ach nee, Mozilla macht
SVG, genau, also Microsoft macht Color und Kepal, Adobe macht SVG, Google macht Zibbeldsk
und Apple macht PNGs im Font. Also es gibt jetzt auch noch drei verschiedene Arten, wie
ein Font eben Informationen darüber speichern kann, wie die Emojis aussehen sollen. Also
entweder auf die Apple Art, die Google Art, die Adobe Mozilla Art oder die Microsoft Art.
Und dann muss der Font-Renderer daraus eben Emojis machen. What the fuck, oder? Das ist
echt nicht mehr normal, was da so passiert. Und dann hast du halt solche Probleme, dass
es nicht richtig funktioniert. Warum ist denn dieses Emoj kaputt? Warum ist dieses, also,
Twi-Emoji, Moment, Twi-Emoji, Twi-Emoji ist so hier. In der Google-Variante allerdings
jetzt. Warum ist dieses Emoji procken? Leute, warum ist dieses, warum ist das hier procken?
Warum ist das, warum ist das procken? Lächeln, das Gesicht Emoji ist procken. Kopieren. Warum
ist das procken? Linux, broken, Emoji. In Noto-Emoji ist es nicht procken. Ah, ist es ein Bug in
Twi-Emoji vielleicht? Okay, wir benutzen mal einen anderen Emoji von. Twi-Emoji, äh,
WTF, Twi-Emoji, alles klar. Kennt ihr noch die alten Android Emojis, diese Blobs? Die
gibt's ja auch schon seit 10 Jahren oder so nicht mehr. Was Noto-Emoji? Äh, welches,
welches davon? Das untere? Ist, ist das untere das richtige jetzt? Okay. Nee, geht, geht
hier auch nicht. Guck, das ist hier auch procken. Das ist hier auch procken. Das ist ein Problem,
das ist ein Bug in aller Kritik, würde ich sagen. Die, die, die haben irgendeinen Bug
bei diesem Emoji, egal welchen Font ich verwende. Steinarter, dankeschön für den Sub. Sind
das auch die, die Westterm standardmäßig hat? Das sind die, oder? Ah, ich vergaß,
das ist ja das Terminal, wo man keine Fonts resizen kann, gescheit. Okay, das ist, das
ist procken das Ding. Okay, das sind, das sind doch eindeutig die Google-Dinger, oder? Also
die verwenden wohl standardmäßig Noto-Emoji in Westterm. Guck mal, und, und hier wird
er gezeichnet, aber in Small. Also irgendwas muss es an diesem Emoji sein, was procken
ist unter Linux. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was, aber irgendwas ist daran kaputt. Es,
es soll, es soll eigentlich so aussehen, eigentlich soll er so aussehen. Weil es gibt,
es gibt das, es gibt das und es gibt das, das sind Unterschiede. Es gibt, es gibt lächelndes
Gesicht und es gibt lächelndes Gesicht mit, mit lachenden Augen. Guck, ha? Lächelndes
Gesicht, lächelndes Gesicht mit lachenden Augen. Lächelndes Gesicht mit lachenden Augen
funktioniert, lächelndes Gesicht funktioniert nicht richtig. Ja, witzigerweise, ich kann
dir sagen, warum es in XFCE-Terminal okay ist, weil in GTK-Basierten ist es okay. Guck,
hier funktioniert es. Es ist aber, dafür stimmt hier der Abstand zwischen den Emojis
nicht mehr. Alter Leute, ich werd verrückt man. Kann, gibt es irgendeinen Terminal und
Fontkombination, wo der Scheiß einfach funktioniert? Ich hab jetzt die Auswahl zwischen C++ Terminals,
die abstürzen, wenn ich Tab drücke. Dinger, wo die Emojis überlappen, wo irgendwelche
Emojis fehlen. Terminals, Terminals, die an sich das Emoji zu kleinmalen und beim Font
resizen schwarz werden. Gibt es das irgendein? Ach du Scheiße man. Suckless ST, das hatte
ich mal eine Weile. Hat Suckless Sixel Support, weil Sixel Support ist auch wichtig, mit Sixel
Support können wir da nämlich Bilder im Terminal rendern. Ich muss mir jetzt mal eine Pro-Con
Liste machen, machen Terminals. Also wir haben, was war das, Sixel Support, Emoji, da gibt
es jetzt das Problem, Emoji Overlappen, das da geht nicht. Das andere geht, geht nicht.
Geht nichts. Das ist die Sache. Man sollte, sollte es resizen können, ohne dass Bildschirm
schwarz wird, nicht crashen, bei Tab drücken. Das wird jetzt unser, das wird jetzt unser
Terminal Test. Und am Ende, am Ende nehmen wir das Terminal, was es kann. Warum man Emojis
braucht? Na, weil Emojis im Terminal essentiell sind mittlerweile. Guckt euch mal die ganzen
JavaScript Tools an, die haben alle irgendwelche komischen Emojis in der Ausgabe. Das muss
sagen, mit Iterm funktioniert es. Und wie heißt die Alternative unter Mac noch mal?
Iterm 2 gibt es, es gibt zwei relativ verbreitete Terminals unter Mac. Iterm und, ich meine
nicht das offizielle. Es gibt noch zwei relativ verbreitete. Ach, keine Ahnung. Iterm hat
mir nichts Probleme, Iterm funktioniert einfach. Leute, wir machen mal kurz den Test. Wie schneidet
denn das Windows Terminal ab? Sekunde, das müssen wir jetzt mal kurz überprüfen. Wie
schneidet, wie schneidet das Windows Terminal in diesem Test ab? Terminal? Das neue natürlich.
Haha! Was ist es? Was ist es mit diesem Emoj, das die Probleme damit haben? Ja gut, die
neuen Emojis verstehst du eh nicht, was Sache ist? Weißt du irgendwas, was sein soll? Guck
mal, das sieht ja unter Windows auch gleich aus beides. Also das ist lachendes Gesicht,
das funktioniert unter Windows auch nicht. Lachendes Gesicht funktioniert nicht, aber
lachendes Gesicht mit lachenden Augen funktioniert. Ich muss den ganzen Krempel echt nicht verstehen.
Zu neue Unicode Version, das ist eine gute Idee. Mal gucken, wann ist lachendes Gesicht
reingekommen? Also lachendes Gesicht ist reingekommen 2015 und das ist 2010, aber trotzdem. Nee,
das ist beides, beides. Kann man das nicht vielleicht mal auf Englisch stellen, dann
kann man auch danach suchen. Alter. Hier unten kann man die Sprache umstellen. Smiling
Face und das andere heißt Smiling Face und Smiling Eyes. Display Issue. Im Browser unter
Windows ist es auch kaputt. Wenn das es unter Firefox funktioniert, pass mal auf, unter
Firefox wird es funktionieren. Unter Firefox funktioniert es, weil Firefox bringt seine
eigenen Emojis mit. Smiling Face Display Issue. Linux.
Gibt es die Firefox Emojis als Schriftart? Ja, die gab es mal. Das alte Emoji One hatte
diese Dinger. Das Ding ist nur das Emoji One, das von Firefox, das alte Emoji One. Eventuell
basieren da auch die Twitter Emojis drauf, keine Ahnung. Können wir es mal vergleichen.
Twitter und Mozilla. Das alte Emoji One waren die Mozilla Dinger und wahrscheinlich auch
die gleichen Vorgänger von Twitter. Was auch immer, ich blick nehme mal durch. Kann es
sein, dass das Problem ist, dass es das Smiling Face Emoji vor den richtigen Emojis gab und
deswegen das Colorless genommen wird zum Rendern. Oh, Craig, das ist eine gute Idee. Das kann
natürlich sein, dass der normale Fond Prio hat. Das kann natürlich wirklich sein, dass
das quasi schon ein bisschen älter ist und der normale Fond das schon kennt und deswegen
kein Emoji Fond genommen wird. Six Head Time, das ist möglich. Mal das mal weg. Okay, okay,
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Wie wir wieder überhaupt nicht das machen, was ich eigentlich
wollte. Okay, TTF to Emoji. Yes. Okay. Machen wir hier mal weg. Jetzt haben wir das Problem,
dass es nicht richtig funktioniert. Genau. So, aber wobei ich muss noch wieder und was
sagt er mir? If you have other Emoji Fonds installed, but want to use, make a Sim link
to Emoji Fond first. You do not need this if you're fine with apps using different Emoji
Fond if you do copy. Ich kann es einfach Sim linken. Okay, Sim linken wir das mal. Pack,
das ist es nicht. Das hat auch, das hat auch Rendering Probleme. Guckt mal. Da fehlt, seht
ihr das? Das hat auch, das hat auch Rendering Probleme. Manchmal sind die Dinge ineinander
und manchmal fehlt unten ein bisschen was. Guckt mal hier fehlt unten ein bisschen. Also
es ist unglaublich, was es für ein Krampf ist, das zum Laufen zu kriegen. Guck mal.
Das eine Terminal rendert es klein, der hier rendert es zusammen. Leute ich, weird, weird,
das Champ, Alter. Ich lösche das mal wieder. Ich lösche das Fall wieder. Wir wollen uns
jetzt aber mal nicht weiter um Emojis kümmern, weil das wird mir schon wieder zu verwirrend.
Ich meine, es wäre natürlich cool, wenn es einfach funktionieren würde, aber nachdem
sogar Windows Probleme teilweise damit hat, würde ich mir denken, okay, da muss so grundsätzlich
irgendwas ein bisschen im Arsch sein. Lustigerweise hier oben hat Windows wiederum keine Probleme
es anzuzeigen. Äußerst, äußerst weird champig alles. Emoji pace. Der Fehler liegt im Ursprung
Unicode war ein Fehler. Aha. Moment, da gibt es wirklich, da gibt es einen Hilfe Eintrag
zu. Okay, okay. Ach so, das war ein Bug in Unicode ursprünglich mal, oder was? MonkaS,
man, das soll mal einer verstehen, Alter. In C9, which is non fully qualified try use,
which is fully qualified emoji sequence. Also das ist jetzt wieder was. Aber mein Browser
hat damit auch Probleme, gell? Nee, das ist aber wieder. Ach so, nee, das finde ich. Aber
der checkt es trotzdem nicht. Okay, das ist irgendein Bug in Unicode, da kümmern uns
scheiß drauf. Ich ignoriere das jetzt, vergiss es. Da befasse ich mich jetzt nicht weiter,
sonst drehe ich hier noch am Rad. Machen wir mal weiter. Da blickt doch keiner mehr
durch. Das ist doch alles nicht mehr normal. Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was ich jetzt verwenden
soll. Das hier kann keine Bilder und Westterm kackt ab beim Resizing. Kitty hat Probleme
bei SSH. MonkaS, was haben wir noch? Was haben wir noch für Terminals zu bieten? Kontur
kackt ab, wenn ich tap tap drücke. Foot gibt es nur für Wayland. Chrome Terminal kann
es. Iterm kann ja alles. Kitty hat keinen Bock darauf. Console kann das. Terminator
wird es auch nicht können, gehe ich mal ganz stark von aus. Terminator steht hier gar
nicht drin. Terminator ist das gleiche wie Gnome Terminal. Unter der Haube ist das alles
dieses VTE Widget von Gnome. Also Console kann es. Aber ich will nicht, ehrlich gesagt,
ich will kein KDE Zeug installieren. Ne, seriously. Nur für so eine fucking Konsole,
BTRFS Programms für eine Konsole, alles klar. Windows kack Ding kann das. Sequent Terminal,
Sequent kann das. Was ist ML Term? Irgendwas. Na, dass es Putin nicht kann, wundert mich
nicht. Ah, es gibt ein TMAX Fork. Sixel TMAX. Jetzt wird es aber. Jetzt wird es high IQ.
Okay, Moment. Ich aninstall TMAX. Hab ich gar nicht drauf. Okay, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Du Scheiße. Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Als erst mal kurz TMAX kompilieren, easy,
kein Problem. Obvius, obvius. Sind eh nicht wirklich nötig. Ne, aber ich finde es cool,
dass man Bilder auf dem Terminal anzeigen kann. Das stimmt schon, dass es ziemlich unsinnig
ist. Aber warum gibt es nicht ein Terminal, was einfach alles kann? Hab ich. Was ist das
jetzt schon wieder? Was? Warum habe ich keine? Ich habe doch Rechte drauf. Zeit für Term
Champion. Ja, ich sehe es schon. Okay, sudo. Permission denied. Alles klar. Geht da schon
mal gut los. Ja, dann nicht. Also an sich muss ich sagen, gefällt mir West Term eigentlich
ganz gut. Leider hat es Resizing Probleme. Das macht Emoji technisch zum größten Teil
die Sachen richtig. Es hat Image Support. Es hat Tiling Support. Wie auch immer man
das benutzt. Kann es Ascii-Quarium rendern? Das ist die Frage. Ascii-Quarium, das Allerwichtigste.
Das ist so, das nach Windows Terminal aussieht, liegt da in der Konfig. Ascii-Quarium. Ascii-Quarium,
die hier unten mit diesen Escape-Dingern von dieser weißen Burg haben viele Probleme. Guck,
guck mal. Allerkritik kann es auch nicht. Da fehlt die weiße Burg. Und die Fische haben
keinen Rand richtig und sowas. Seht ihr? Okay, ein weiterer Test für unser Ascii-Quarium.
Das Ascii-Quarium richtig darstellen. Okay, West Term Konfig. Was hat es für... Bei dir
macht es das korrekt? Was hast du eingestellt? Vielleicht ein anderes Farbschema. Hier, das
kann das auch. Aber da wird man ja richtig geplendet. Also hier ist Procken unten. Du
musst nach der Burg gucken. Ah, Moment. Die Burg ist... Na gut, die wird halt plus nie richtig
angezeigt. Okay, Konfig. Theme oder was soll ich suchen? Nee. Color? Das Windows-Terminal,
keine Ahnung. Ich habe Ascii-Quarium nicht für Windows. Colors, Tomorrow Nights. Ich
meine, das können wir natürlich ausprobieren. Dann ist es schön buntig, buntig alles, ja.
Ruby, Ruby brauchen wir natürlich. Was sonst? Ruby. Okay, Ascii-Quarium nach Lolcat. Exzellent.
Okay, es liegt wahrscheinlich an irgendwelchen Farbschemasachen, dass es die Abstufung nicht
richtig anzeigt. Aber an sich wird das funktionieren. Da muss man wahrscheinlich, da muss man wahrscheinlich
hier die Colors. Okay, standardmäßig sind Colors die Tomorrow Night Colors. Moment,
West-Term-Config. Alter, was? Alter, warum muss das in Lua-Config sein? Please, Lua-Config.
Was machst du an? Du meinst in einem Video zu Ascii, oder was? Hat es nicht einfach
eine Konfig-Datei? Ich will kein Lua programmieren. Ich will, please, ich will kein Lua programmieren
um irgendwie Colors-Schemes einzustellen. Es macht mich fertig. Ich...
Example. Return Colors. Okay, West-Term.Lua. Wo muss das hin?
Home. West-Term.Lua. Okay. Lua. Alter, mir widerstrebt es extrem... Mir widerstrebt es
extrem, dass ich... Oh, falsches Verzeichnis. Jetzt haben wir Batman-Colors-Scheme, Leute.
Batman. Das ist so dark, da erkennst du gar nichts. So, was haben wir? Colour? Colour?
Colour-Schemes. So. Ordentlich. Tomorrow. Tomorrow. Das mag ich. Das habe ich schon
öfter. Tomorrow-Dark. Tomorrow-Light. Tomorrow-Night. Ja, Tomorrow-Night ist nice, ist nice, ist
Colour-Scheme. Das mag ich. Tomorrow-Night. Okay. Was hast du hier sonst noch? Tomorrow-Dark-Terminal.Sexy.
Was ist das für... 2017. Create View and Edit Terminal Colour-Schemes. Warum gibt es Tomorrow-Dark
und Tomorrow-Night? Das ist mehr oder weniger das Gleiche. Okay, schreiben wir das mal rein.
Und was gibt es... Ach, guck mal. Der hat gleich reloadet. Der hat gleich reloadet. Okay.
Und jetzt, Ascii-Quarium, ist es jetzt broken? Jetzt ist es hier auch... Das sieht aber falsch
aus. Jetzt ist es aber hier auch broken. Nee, Kitty ist laut eigener Aussage vom Autor...
Nicht dafür gemacht, ordentlich kompatibel mit TMUX zu sein. Und nachdem ich... Und Probleme
wohl irgendwie zu haben mit SSH, wenn Terminal-Zeug nicht richtig gesetzt ist. URXVT. URXVT.
Und weil sie irgendwie Probleme hat mit TMUX-Sessions. Und TMUX ist tatsächlich was, was ich täglich
mehrfach brauche. Ich würde mich ja damit anfreunden können, dass es nicht lokal funktioniert,
ja. Aber zumindest sollte es funktionieren remote über SSH-Geschleid. Okay, das liegt
am Colour-Scheme, dass es das verkehrt rendert. Machen wir mal was anderes. Oh, ich muss
mal eine Vim... Vim... Andu... Andu-Config. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, Batman. War das da oder?
Batman. Bin überhaupt nicht drinne. Ascii-Quarium. Ja, da rennt er das nämlich richtig. Nee,
TMUX muss man nicht tutorial... Tutorialen. Ah, da sieht es richtig aus. Es ist natürlich
ganz schön blöd, dass man hier nicht durchscrollen kann, dass es nach... Okay, da machen wir
nicht... Base 16 habe ich auch teilweise verwendet. Tango Base 16, Fender Base 16, Twilight Base
16. Okay, das war's. Auch noch Tomorrow Dark Terminal Punkt Sexy hätten wir auch noch
zu bieten. Zumindest mag ich da schon mal, dass der automatisch alles reloadet. Aha,
die haben es wohl ein bisschen gefixt. Weil ich glaube, wenn ich in meiner normalen V-M
stehe, ich glaube, da ist das Ascii-Quarium auch kaputt. Mal hier gucken, das ist das,
was ich seit Jahren schon verwende. Da ist das Ascii-Quarium nämlich mit dem Tomorrow
Theme auch kaputt. Das finde ich ganz nice. Guckt mal. Also, wenn man wissen will, ob
es funktioniert, muss man die Sachen in X-Term... X-Term. Ja, also, wie gesagt, wenn man wissen
will, ob was funktioniert, das ist teilweise wirklich so, dann muss man... Guck mal, X-Term
installieren. Ich bin blind, Alter. Ich muss mal kurz... So, wenn man nämlich X-Term aufmacht
und wenn was in X-Term funktioniert, dann weißt du prinzipiell... Also, in X-Term weißt du,
wie es aussehen soll. X-Term kann irgendwie alles. Auch außer moderne Fonts gescheit.
Aber X-Term unterstützt wirklich irgendwie 40 Jahre alle Unix-Linux-Abartigkeiten, die
sich mal irgendjemand ausgedacht hat. Guck mal, zum Beispiel dieser Fisch hier, der hat
gar keine Rand. Guck mal. Das ist aber normal, die haben auch keine Rand hier. Das ist der
ASCII-Quarium-Benchmark. Moment, konnte man ASCII-Quarium nicht auch mit unterschiedlich
vielen FPS laufen lassen? Minus C? Ich meine, es wäre cool, wenn es sowas wie Minus-Minus-Help
gäbe, aber gibt es ja anscheinend nicht. Da müssen wir jetzt in Source-Code jetzt wahrscheinlich
gucken. Das ist Pearl. ASCII-Quarium ist Pearl. Jetzt wird es richtig abartig. Plastic. Nee,
gibt es nicht. Es gibt kein FPS-Switch. Sowas kann es nicht. Ah, Moment hier. Nee,
sowas gibt es nicht. Leute, Source-Code ASCII-Quarium. 1472 Zeilen Pearl. MonkaS. Jetzt hab ASCII-Quarium.
Vor 11 Jahren. Beste. Classic Mode. Only show species from ASCII-Quarium 1.0. Ey, das müsste
echt mal jemand updaten. Warum gibt es noch kein ASCII-Quarium Blazingly Fast Written
in Rust? Das gibt es bestimmt in Rust schon. Es ist nicht Written in Rust, Alter. Blazingly
Fast Written in Rust. ASCII-Quarium Git. Guck mal hier. Da gibt es eine neue Version.
Nee, aber das ist eh das Gleiche. With Optional Transparent Background. Rusty ASCII-Quarium.
Excellent, Leute. Jawoll. Nee, nee, das ist doch nichts. Das ist doch nichts. Ich will
ASCII. Nicht, nicht, nicht sowas hier. Web-Demo. Es geht wahrscheinlich jetzt bei mir in der
Web gar nicht richtig. Ach doch. Das ist mir zu photorealistisch. Ich bleib lieber hierbei.
About Lemmings. Also anscheinend kann man es nur. Man konnte mal nicht in die Taste drücken.
Ach hier, guck mal hier. High Speed ASCII-Quarium. Du hast es gefunden mit den FPS. Ja, erzähl.
Also man kann die Taste gedrückt halten, dann geht das. In Java. Ich installiere mir garantiert
kein ASCII-Quarium in Java. Ok, Terminal Benchmark beendet. Also ohne Scheiß, ich muss euch sagen,
so rein von den Features her, auch wenn es Probleme mit dem Resizen hat, was mich ja
jetzt ein bisschen abfuckt, gefällt mir Vesturm tatsächlich gar nicht mal so schlecht. Moment,
es benutzt den falschen Emoji-Font. Es ist schlimm. Es ist schlimm. Warum gibt es kein
fucking Terminal, was alles kann? Wie macht man jetzt Tiling da drinnen? Emoji. Ja,
hier kann man die Fonts ändern. Config with Fallback. Alter, ich will einfach den fucking
Font ändern und nicht Lua lernen. Return Color Scheme. Ja und weiter, wie geht das jetzt?
Font. Ok, Font gleich. Ich glaube es nicht. Ich muss Lua, ich muss ernsthaft Lua programmieren
für den Terminal-Config. JetBrains Mono. Ok, das kann jetzt nicht funktionieren, weil
ich habe kein JetBrains Mono installiert. Alter, ich habe kein JetBrains Mono installiert.
Bäm. Weißt du, gleich mal broken. Ich will Hack-Font haben. Hack. Ah, jetzt haben wir
schon mal gut. Hack. Jetzt kann man die Größe hinten angeben. 16. Nope. Nope. Nope. Broke.
Wie macht man da jetzt Font-Size? Wie macht man da jetzt Font-Size? Alter, ich habe wirklich
keinen Bock für Terminal-Config Lua zu lernen. Aber an sich, also auch das Auto reloaden
und so, das finde ich tatsächlich ganz, ganz cool. Ach, hier kann man die, wie macht man
da die Größe? Wait, bold, italic. Wie macht man die Font-Size? Font-Size, hier. Ah ja,
alles klar. Und wie soll das jetzt funktionieren? Einfach so Font-Size? Also quasi Font-Size?
Alter, ich kann ja mal schreiben. Und jetzt? 16. 18, 19. Ach, vielleicht ist es einfach
nur so. Wobei, es ist Lua, dann muss man wahrscheinlich 18 so schreiben. Ah ja. Okay, nice. Nice.
Okay, okay, das sieht, das sieht, das sieht auch ganz brauchbar aus. Das sieht auch ganz
brauchbar aus. Okay, ja, nice, nice, nice. Ich meine, ich muss vielleicht auch gar nicht
so oft resize. Es buggt halt ein bisschen beim resize, aber okay. Das finde ich, finde ich
tatsächlich ganz sympathisch aktuell. Vesterm. Vesterm. So. Wir schauen mal kurz, ob resize,
ob es da schon ein Bugreport zugibt. Oh, ja. Ein paar, würde ich sagen. Bad prompt on
resize behavior. Was? Ja, das ist kaputt. Ich will ja gar nicht resizen. Moment, vielleicht
resize sehe ich. Ich stelle glaube ich Zoom ein anstatt Font-Size. Kann das sein, dass
ich mit den Shortcuts gar kein Font-Size mache, sondern den Zoom-Level irgendwie verändere?
So, wie auch immer. Das einzige, was ich jetzt noch mache, ich möchte Emoji, Emoji-Fonts
ändern, please. Emoji. Fonts. Not all Emojis are rendered. Fonts. Hier. Fonts. Vesterm
LS Fonts. Okay. Build in. JetBrains Mono. Es ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, Leute,
dass das Ding ein paar sinnvolle eingebaute Emoji-Fonts mitbringt. So geht es nämlich
einfach immer. Eigentlich gar nicht blöd. Guck mal, da bringt auch ein Nerdfont Symbols
mit. Eigentlich ist das wirklich gut durchdacht. Das gefällt mir. Ich glaube, ich habe dem
Unrecht getan am Anfang, dass ich es gleich wieder runtergeschmissen habe. Das überzeugt
mich bis jetzt fast am meisten von den ganzen neuen Terminals. Das Copy-Paste muss ich mich
noch dran gewöhnen. Man muss ja quasi rechts klicken und dann kann man... Nee. Naja, mittlere
Maustaste geht. Also das ist ein bisschen... Aber das Clipboard kann man bestimmt umstellen.
Der Fabian. Also ich weiß nicht, was er aktuell macht. Ich weiß, dass er Unterhosen gemodelt
hat. Wer ist denn John Reed? Ok, ok, Fabian. Es gibt da Fotos von. Ich weiß, dass er Unterhosen
gemodelt hat, der Fabian. Videos. Ok, zeig mal, zeig mal. Schick mal, schick mal, wir
sind in Frasier. Den Frasier im Werbevideo. Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken. Der Fabian,
der hätte sein... Also ich weiß, er wollte nicht, aber der Fabian wäre der perfekte,
ohne Scheiß, der Fabian wäre der perfekte Männer-Beauty-Influencer geworden. Ja, Rick
Roll, alles klar. Der Fabian wäre der perfekte Männer-Beauty-Influencer geworden. Der hat
ja auch mal ein paar Videos gemacht, so wie föhne ich mir die Haare richtig und sowas.
Das hat 140.000 Views oder so gehabt. Der Fabian, der hätte wirklich alles gehabt für
so einen männlichen Beauty-Influencer. Der hat Ahnung gehabt von dem, was er erzählt,
im Vergleich zu den meisten anderen Influencern. Ich meine, er hat Friseur gelernt. Der konnte
das auch gut. Der mochte so Beauty-Sachen. Der sah auch noch richtig gut aus für solche
Geschichten. Also der Fabian hatte die Optik gehabt für so einen Beauty-Influencer. Aber
gut, ich weiß, warum er das nicht gemacht hat. Weil ihn die Leute abgefuckt haben. Und
wenn der Fabian damals schon von den dummen Leuten auf YouTube abgefuckt ist, was meint
ihr, was heute gewesen wäre? Ich meine, heute ist es nicht besser geworden. Der hätte heute
3 Millionen Abos gehabt als Beauty-Influencer. Der Friseur hätte damals weiter gemacht mit.
Ich möchte eigentlich rechte Maustaste. Ich will, dass er rechte Maustaste in mein Clipboard
pastet. Ja, ja, ist blöd. Ich will jetzt noch mal kurz gucken, wie man den Emoji-Font
umstellt. Ich mache weiter so. Ich weiß gerade nicht, was ich als nächstes aufnehme. Okay,
wie macht man Emoji-Fonts hier drinnen? Das kann doch nicht so schwierig sein. Also ich
bin wirklich ein bisschen planbar. Wie macht man einen Emoji-Font? Emoji, Emoji-Font.
Default Configuration. Also ich bin, ich bin da wirklich zu blöd, das zu setzen, ehrlich
gesagt. Font-Rules? Ey, oder? Nein, keine. Ey, das ist nicht der Fabian, den man da sieht
in dem Video. So. Change Emoji-Font. Font-Rules? Okay, Custom Emoji-Font. Wie hat der Dude
das gemacht? Ach, man gibt das einfach da hinten an? Moment. Font-with-fallback. Ich
bin verwirrt. Was? Okay, also macht man nicht so, sondern macht so. Sagt dann Hack. Sollte
sicher nichts. Natürlich, was sonst? Exzellent. Was ist verkehrt? Komma fehlt. Okay, das funktioniert.
Und jetzt sage ich 3 Emoji. So. Und jetzt paste, wenn man Emojis, er soll es ja checken.
Ey, funktioniert, oder? Funktioniert. Jetzt mal, ich mach das mal kurz kaputt. Ja, das
ist ja easy. Okay, so schlimm ist das mit Lua-Config doch gar nicht. Guck mal, man funktioniert
doch ganz brauchbar eigentlich. Funktioniert doch ganz okay. Der war richtig gehypt auf
das neue Konfig. Ja, ich hab ihn im Discord. Man sieht ja, was die Leute da so spielen
aktuell. Hab ich auch gewundert, dass er Modern Warfare spielt. Ja, ist doch ganz gute
Konfig so. Animation FPS. Was für ein Ding. Wir müssen übrigens noch mehr ausprobieren.
Animation FPS. Was? If you're running CPU-Renderer, then setting animations as doing so will
disable easing effects and use transitions. Mir ist bis jetzt nicht klar gewesen, dass
mein Terminal irgendwelche Transitions hat. Okay, was ist jetzt? Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Ascii-Quarium? Meint das nicht, dass es damit was zu tun hätte? Eins. Hat das jetzt irgendein
Unterschied? Nicht wirklich, oder? Frontend Software. Also ohne GPU. Es ist absolut kein
Unterschied dazwischen. Nee, nicht die Window-Size. Wenn ich mit dem Shortcut die Font größer
und kleiner machen will, dann macht er das Fenster größer und kleiner, was er ja nicht
machen soll. Ich will die Font kleiner machen und da hat er im Tiling-Window-Manager ein
Problem. Das ist bestimmt eine reine Konfig-Geschichte, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich pepega.
Sobald ich das hier nämlich bewege, ist alles wieder gut. Chat plickt wieder durch. Was?
Alter, wie kommt man denn da drauf? Adjust Window-Size when changing Font-Size. Und jetzt
eins. Nee. So. Alter, ist ja gut. Zwei. Eins. Ok, das ist, oder muss da True? Ah,
das ist, Pauls, alles klar. Hey! Chat, es funktioniert! Paulgars! Es gefällt mir eigentlich
ganz gut. Das ist aber eher Zoom-Level, was ich hier mache. Da muss ich mich mal ein bisschen
einarbeiten. Ich finde, ich finde, ok, aber ich muss sagen, mir gefällt das. Mir gefällt
das wirklich ganz gut. Jetzt, was ist denn, was ist denn, das kann ja angeblich auch tiling.
Wie macht man dann, mach das hier mal kurz raus, wie macht man denn, wie teilt man da
jetzt Windows, also wie macht man, Split zum Beispiel, Split-Pay-Invest-Term-CLI. Ok,
also sowas würde ich jetzt machen. Genau. Hey, ich muss sagen, also ohne Scheiß, ich
habe, ich habe dem unrecht getan am Anfang. Das gefällt mir, glaube ich, von allen Terminals,
die ich ausprobiert habe, bisher am besten. Also von denen, die ich heute ausprobiert habe,
mit am besten. Das ist cool, das hat was. Das Font-Rendering sieht sauber aus. Performance
scheint mir ganz ok zu sein. Es hat, es hat ganz wichtig, Image, Image-Support. Also
das allerwichtigste überhaupt, wir müssen animierte Anime-Gifts im Terminal abspielen
können. Ich stelle mal vor, das wäre undenkbar, wenn das nicht funktionieren würde. Ich kann
White, White-Pepo-Happy rendern im Background. Kann man 50% sagen oder so? Geht das auch?
10%? Checkt er nicht. White-Pepo-Happy kann man rendern im Terminal. Das ist natürlich
enorm wichtig. Window, ich muss mir das mal angucken. Ich muss mir das mal angucken.
Ich meine, ich wollte zwar nicht nur lernen, um ein Terminal zu konfigurieren, aber an
sich, es hat, es hat was, muss ich sagen, es hat was. Ich finde das cool, gefällt mir.
Ok, alles klar. Man kann verschiedene Tabs aufmachen. Na ja, ich glaube, sobald es ein
bisschen komplizierter wird, gibt es denn, was sagt denn die Standard-Config dazu? Wie
kann man, wie kann man splitten? Also man kann es aber in der Konfig auf jeden Fall.
Was sind denn die Default, was sind denn die Default-Key? West-Term-Default-Key-Bindings.
Default-Key-Assignments. Split? Ok, Ctrl-Shift-Alt. Moment, was? Nee, Split. Ctrl-Shift-Alt.
Leute, da breche ich mir den Finger ab. Ctrl-Shift-Alt. Also da breche ich mir komplett den Finger
ab, bis ich das getippt habe. Ctrl-Shift-Alt. Ok, es sind die, es sind die T-Max-Bindings,
es sind die T-Max-Bindings, aber, aber ganz schlimm, das muss ich, das muss ich irgendwie
umlegen. Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier? As-Ctrl? Ah, kann man Tab-Switchen? Ok. Also
was haben wir denn hier? Super und C. Copy to Clipboard. Ah, das heißt, ich klick was
an und drücke Windows-Taste und C und dann kann ich, ne, Windows-Taste und C. Ach, da
wäre ich mich nicht dran gewöhnen können. Ich bin so Ctrl-C-Spammer und Ctrl-V im Browser.
Im Terminal geht das ja mit Ctrl-V nicht, deswegen, deswegen muss ich sagen, ich kopiere
ehrlich gesagt am liebsten mit Rechtsklick. Also Rechtsklick kopieren finde ich, finde
ich, irgendwie, habe ich mich dran gewöhnt. Ctrl-Shift-C geht auch. Insert Super-Hide-Window,
Spawn-Window, Toggle-Fullscreen, Decrease-Font-Side-Increase, Reset-Font-Sides. Ok, das ist auch ganz praktisch,
wenn man hier irgendwie komische Dinger gemacht hat, dann sagt man Null. Ok, nice. Not found.
Warum ist mein Terminal eigentlich so blöd hier unten? Hier fehlt die letzte Zeile. Scroll-Wheel-Scrollen?
Finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch. So, jetzt haben wir hier Spawn, Spawn-Tab, also sprich
Windows-Dings, ganz klar. Ja, das sind Sachen, die kann man sich merken. Ich werde das eh
irgendwie sinnvoll konfigurieren für mich. Spawn-Curse, Close-Curse, Activate-Tab, 123,
ja, ist ganz gut. Ctrl-Shift-Activate-Tab, Tab-Rell, ok, ganz viel Tab-Handling, Scroll-By-Page,
Scroll-Configuration, Hide-Application, Debug-Overlay, sieht man dann Ctrl-Shift-L? Sieht man dann
die FPS? Ok. Boah, ah, nix wie weg wieder. Activate-Copy-Mode, was ist Copy-Mode? Ok,
ok. Activate-Copy-Mode, learn more about Copy-Mode, die Docs bin ich auch gut gemacht, da verstehst
du wenigstens was. Copy-Mode allows you to make selections using keyboard, no need to
reach for your mouse or trackpad, Copy-Mode is similar to Quick-Select-Mode. Quick-Select-Mode.
Geht da ein Wim auf oder was? Jetzt, das ist mir zu high IQ jetzt. Was? Ctrl-Shift-Space,
Split? Way too dank, ich weiß nicht mal was es macht. Ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok. Type-Highlighted-Prefix-To-Copy. What? Ok, ich hab keine Ahnung was es tut. Ctrl-Shift-Space,
Highlighted-Prefix-To-Copy. Kann es sein, dass mein Bild, mein Bild-Output das irgendwie
ein bisschen zerstört hat? Vor allem, warum sind wir hier oben und nicht sonst wo? Ok,
keine Ahnung. Wir probieren gerade ein neues Terminal aus. Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich das
glaube ich. Ok Leute, wir machen was. Pass mal auf. GitHub, wir klonen mal kurz, wir
klonen mal kurz den Repo von mir. Code, mkdir, Repos. So, und jetzt geben wir mal Git-Log
und jetzt mache ich das nochmal. Ach, jetzt funktioniert das. Ok, jetzt kann ich zum Beispiel
sagen, ich möchte hier hinspringen. So, dahin. Da drücke ich jetzt V. Ok, das ist, das ist
mega high IQ. Keine Ahnung ob ich das jemals verwenden werde. Scrollback. Searching Scrollback
by default, ctrl shift f. Jetzt kann ich scrollback, wo bloß? Ach ja, ok, das ist tatsächlich
ganz nützlich. Kann ich meine, jetzt kann ich quasi meinen Scrollback-Buffer durchsuchen.
Das ist sehr praktisch. Das geht in T-Max auch. Das ist in T-Max bloß extrem träge.
Das heißt, wie jump ich jetzt zum nächsten? Ach so, einfach hier, einfach hoch. Das, ohne
Scheiß, Leute. Das gefällt mir, das Terminal. Volle Dankeschön für den Sub. Was? Ich war
by the way mal letztes Jahr im Juli hier bzw. könnte sein, dass ich mich da noch dran erinnere.
Ganz, ganz dunkel, ja. Beprüfen wir das mal. Messages 200. Ich stalke mal kurz dein Profil.
Du warst, ja stimmt, du warst, du warst, du warst letztes Jahr hier, das ist korrekt.
Du warst letztes, du warst im Dezember einmal da und dann letztes Jahr im Juni irgendwann,
genau. Du hast gesagt Vorstellungsgespräch, genau Vorstellungsgespräch, jetzt sogar für
Physi. Alles klar, ja stimmt, ich kann mich dunkel dran erinnern. Drei Monate später
wurde ich geframed und raus, was bedeutet denn geframed? In dem Zusammenhang, was, was
heißt das? Geframed und rausgehauen. Jetzt wurde ich vorgestern der Hochschule für Informalkostal,
hatte einen Kollegen beleidigt, vielleicht hat er es verdient. Kommt drauf an, was man
sagt, man sollte sich da schon teilweise zusammenreißen. Also du solltest jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen,
du dummer Hurensohn, ich fick deine Mutter oder so. Das ist vielleicht bisschen unkollegial.
Das ist schon, das ist schon nicht so nett. Und je nachdem wie der Typ drauf ist, also
es kommt drauf an, ja. Also wenn man lustig auf der Arbeit drauf ist und die Leute sich
verstehen und man ab und zu, ab und zu sich ein bisschen gegenseitig, so ein bisschen
ärgert, so just for fun, dann ist das ja kein Problem. Wenn das, wenn das so, wie soll
ich sagen, also wenn man, wenn alle okay damit sind, ja dann ist das, ja. Zum Beispiel mache
ich auch permanent Witze über, über einen Kollege bei mir, weil er so dick ist und der
über mich auch. Also das ist dann wieder was anderes. So und, aber das ist natürlich,
das ist eine fiese, fiese Geschichte. Und du warst es nicht, sagst du. Also sprich man
hat es dir in die Schuhe geschoben. Na gut, ich meine ich würde jetzt auch sagen, dass
ich nicht gewesen bin. Aber man hat es dir in die Schuhe geschoben. Ist halt blöd, du
bist noch in der Probezeit gewesen und dann konnten sie dich einfach kicken. Aber mal
davon abgesehen, man hätte es doch bestimmt irgendwie rausbekommen, wenn das eine Linux,
wenn das eine Linux-Kiste ist, hätte man das doch sicherlich rausbekommen, so ein bisschen
anhand der Login-IPs und sowas wäre es gewesen ist. Oder konnten die dich eh schon nicht
ab. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, also seriously, ich hätte dich dafür, wenn ich dich, also
mal angenommen, ich wäre zufrieden mit dir, würde ich dich dafür nicht kicken. Ich würde
dich, ich würde dich vielleicht, je nachdem, also wenn ich da, wenn ich da Chef wäre,
wie kommt man hier wieder raus, also wenn ich da Chef wäre und ich da die Vermutung hätte,
hast du da andere Kollegen beleidigt, das würde ich mal ordentlich, wie soll ich sagen,
zurechtweisen, dass sich das doch nicht gehört, aber ich würde dich wahrscheinlich nicht
kicken. Und wahrscheinlich wollten sie dich eh loswerden, kann durchaus sein. Also das
ist ja schon sehr sass, das ist ja schon sehr sass, wenn du nicht mal der Chef, also ganz
ehrlich, wahrscheinlich wollten die dich loswerden, dann haben sie aber wahrscheinlich, dann
haben sie es auch nicht verdient, dass ein gescheiter Azubi haben. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr,
was das blöde ist? Wisst ihr, was das blöde ist? Dass man sich auch im professionellen
Umfeld, in beide Richtungen, ich meine, ich glaube dir jetzt einfach mal, dass du es nicht
gewesen bist, du könntest uns ja ja auch irgendeinen Mist erzählen, vielleicht warst es ja doch,
dass man sich im professionellen Umfeld, je nachdem jetzt in welche Richtung mit so einem
Scheiß rumschlagen muss, ja. Naja, aber du warst die ersten sechs Monate noch da, also
da geht das ja relativ zackig. Ja, sagt, vielleicht hast du ja Glück, vielleicht hast du wirklich
Glück, mein, vielleicht ist es jetzt ja unterm Strich besser. Patrick, ich habe so ein bisschen
meine Vermutung, dass da nicht alles so ganz ist. Oh, was ist das hier? Warum habe ich
jetzt so... Warum habe ich gerade auf einmal da jetzt so ein... Ok, so, also Westherm finde
ich tatsächlich ganz nice, gefällt mir. Ich glaube, das werde ich mal ein bisschen,
das werde ich mal ein bisschen verwenden und auch hier mit diesem, mit diesem Search Mode
und sowas, hat was. Wir gucken mal kurz, wir schauen mal kurz, wie performant das Ganze
ist. Jemand eine schlaue Idee, wie man viel Text Output machen kann, der Sinn ergibt?
Warte mal, wir können Gitlog machen? Ich weiß, wie wir das machen. Ganz einfach. Repos,
Vierchamp. Nee, Yes ist doof, habe ich doch gerade schon gemacht. Es gibt immer nur eine
Sache aus. Nee, ich will sinnvolle Text Output machen, also sowas hier im Endeffekt. Ja,
sowas, sowas hier im Endeffekt will ich machen. Wild, true, do, done. So, jetzt haben wir
genug. Der Scrollback Buffer ist standardmäßig wie lang? Man hat, man hat keine Anzeige.
Ach, der Scrollback Buffer ist gar nicht so lang. Es ist bloß, ist, woah. Ist gar nicht
so lang, ok. Aber ich finde es trotzdem ganz gut durchdacht, hat echt was. Ok, wir müssen
auf jeden Fall scrollen. Wir müssen auf jeden Fall den Scrollback höher stellen. Ok, scrollbar
können wir auch machen, auch nicht verkehrt. Vesturm, scrollbar, true, true, lulw. Leute,
erkennt ihrs? Kackel, jetzt, jetzt aber bitte. Please, noch unkenntlicher machen die scrollbar.
Erkennt ihr das überhaupt? Also ich erkenne es ganz, ganz leicht, dass hier eine scrollbar
ist. Ok, das ist schon wirklich ziemlich nichtzahmend. Man kann es bestimmt, man kann bestimmt die
scrollbar color. Hier, scrollbar thumb, da kann man das angeben. Es ist wirklich, ich
mag, mir gefällt es. Mir gefällt es wirklich. Ich hab, ich hab Unrecht, ich hab den Unrecht
getan, dass ich am Anfang gesagt hab, ah hier irgendwie ist Mist. Gefällt mir von allen
Sachen, die ich bisher ausprobiert hab, eigentlich am besten. Was, scrollback lines? Scrollback
lines ist wie viele Zeilen er sich merkt. Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
hoch stellen. Scrollback lines darf, darf ohne Probleme irgendwie mal hier einiges sein.
Quatsch, bam, voll, der Ram, der Ram muss voll werden. Probieren wir mal, ob ich mir
das richtig gemerkt habe. Aha, aha, hab ich. Mach die Ram-Auslastung, 3 gig, oh wie switche
ich jetzt eigentlich rüber? Reinklicken? Yes, Ram-Auslastung, jawoll. Das ist halt
nur Text, da sind auch 100, da sind auch eine Million Zeilen Text, jetzt nicht so wild.
Oh, oh, oh, er ist ja gut. F. Es geht, ohne Scheiß, also performen,
also performance ist doch vollkommen okay. Wir haben 57.000 Zeilen gematcht, überhaupt
kein Ding. Mag ich, gefällt mir, es hat was. Ich glaube, ich glaube das werde ich öfters,
das werde ich öfters verwenden. Ich glaube das werde ich öfters verwenden. Und wenn
man clear macht, dann löscht er auch wirklich komplett. Also hier, so jetzt kann ich ganz
viel scrollback machen und kann hochkommen, wenn ich clear mache, sehe ich, wie in T-Max,
wo noch alles da ist. Jetzt ist es auch weg, wenn ich sage clear. Okay, alles wunderbar,
Copy Mode, habe ich immer noch nicht verstanden, was das sein soll. Was haben wir hier, Control-Shift-C,
was war das? Control-Shift-X, Search, Jan. Oh, Monkeys, was jetzt? Ach, jetzt kann man
so Selections machen und sowas. Okay, da werde ich mich reinfinden, denke ich. Aber ich muss
sagen, das gefällt mir wirklich ganz gut. Ich glaube, das muss ich mir im Detail noch
mal ein bisschen angucken. Also dann schmeißen wir das mal runter und was habe ich noch installiert?
Tillix. Was war das hier noch mal? Das war so das VTE-basierte, ja, okay. Wir machen noch.
Okay, nice. Also das Terminal gefällt mir tatsächlich richtig, richtig gut. Jetzt ist
es noch praktisch schwer, irgendeine Schriftgröße zu finden, wo hier nicht fast eine komplette
Zeile verloren geht. Guck mal, es geht fast eine komplette Zeile verloren. Das können
wir aber wahrscheinlich fixen, indem man, Wim, West-Turm. Und jetzt kann man doch sicherlich
sagen, wie groß diese Zeile da oben sein soll. Dass man jetzt sagen kann, irgendwas mit Bar
wird das wahrscheinlich heißen. Tab Bar, Appearance und Colors. Tab Bar Max Width, Use Fancy Tab
Bar. Was ist Use Fancy Tab Bar? High IQ Tab Bar. Use Fancy Tab Bar. Das ist genauso, Fancy
ist Default. Ah, das ist die Unfancy. Fancy ist schon besser, oder? Das ist auch nicht
schlechtes. Fancy ist schon ein bisschen Fancy, egal. Aber wie kann man denn die Höhe einstellen
von dem Ding? Use Enable Tab Bar. Hide Tab Bar, if only one Tab. Ja, das ist gut. Das
finde ich, das finde ich sinnvoll. Man braucht ja, man braucht ja keine Leiste, wenn es nur
einen Tab gibt. Was ist denn das eigentlich? Warum rendert er denn die letzten, warum rendert
er die letzte Zeile nicht? Pepega Turm. In der Taskleiste zeige ich gar nichts an. Das
ist ganz normales i3 Status. Gar nichts. Hier, ganz, ganz, wenn ich was gucken will, mache
ich Hardtop und gut ist. Ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist, wenn ich jetzt auf 15 stelle.
Also irgendwie, irgendwie hat er immer ziemlich einen Platz oben und unten. Da müsste doch
eigentlich noch, da müsste doch eigentlich noch eine Zeile hinpassen, oder? Da müsste
doch noch eine Zeile unten drunter passen. Ich bin in der VM, ja. Aber hat was. Also
ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich glaube, dass das Terminal werde ich mal eine Weile ausprobieren.
Das kann man auch schön customisieren, das gefällt mir. Und das allerbeste, Leute, das
allerbeste, GIFs in der Konsole. Leute, GIFs in der Konsole. So muss das sein. Endlich,
endlich habe ich mal eine sinnvolle Anwendung für Bilder in der Konsole gefunden. Ich bin
in der VM, ja. Die letzte Zeile ist für Powerline gedacht. Ok, das könnte tatsächlich. Oh Leute,
das Terminal ist zu schnell, ich kann nicht Ctrl 10. Ich habe eine Endlosschleife, die
ich nicht abbrechen kann. Was ist da los? Kill all bash. Blöde Idee. Kill all. Ja,
wie wird es wahrscheinlich sein? Pass auf. Bam. Ja, die letzte, die letzte Zeile. Warum
ist das? Also was ich auch noch, was ich auch noch ausprobieren will. Top Bar at Bottom.
Können wir auch mal ausprobieren. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei T-Max. Das ist vielleicht
gar nicht so schlecht. Probieren wir mal aus. Was war das? Da muss ich mal ein neues Tab
aufmachen. Da habe ich vergessen, wie es geht. Was ist das Default-Binding für Tab? Ok. Tab
Bar at Bottom. Gleich True. Jetzt hat er auch wieder einen doof Platz unten drunter. Wobei
ich es tatsächlich praktischer finde, wenn es unten ist. Dann sieht es ein bisschen T-Max
styliger aus. Use Fancy Tab Bar. Dann können wir es auch auf False stellen. Das sieht fast
aus wie T-Max Leute jetzt. Guck mal. Ohne Scheiß. Ich glaube, wenn es einer nicht weiß,
was das Terminal ist, dann könnte man denken, das ist ein T-Max. Ich glaube, ich lasse das
so. Ich glaube, ich lasse das so gewöhnungsmäßig. Dass hier natürlich unten immer so eine Zeile
frei ist, ist schon ziemlich doof. Das kann man aber wahrscheinlich auch konfigurieren.
Welche VORAM Software benutzt du? Das ist VORAM Workstation. Allerdings VORAM Workstation
mit 8, 8 CPUs und 64G RAM. Auf einer ziemlich schnellen Kiste. Jetzt muss ich mir nur dran
gewöhnen, mit welchen Tastenkombis ich das switche. Eines ist komisch, es ist ein bisschen
laggy beim Clearen. Also so richtig blazingly fast ist es nicht. Und auch so ein bisschen
laggy. Guckt mal. Ein bisschen laggy ist es. Ich halte jetzt Enter gedrückt. Leute, das
ist laggy. Guck mal. Pass mal auf. Ich sage euch mal, ich sage mal, wann ich aufgehört
abzudrücken. Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Und jetzt. Seht ihr? Das leckt, wenn sich zu viel
aufgestaut hat. Ich meine, im täglichen Arbeiten ist es wahrscheinlich nicht großartig
relevant. Aber trotzdem. Das rumgelegel muss ja nicht sein. Ritzino, oder? Eigentlich schon
für den Sub. Warum muss man im Terminal beim Kopieren und Einfügen zusätzlich Shift drücken?
Musst du nicht. Du kannst auch mit der Maus machen. Ansonsten, warum du nicht Ctrl C drücken
kannst du ganz einfach, weil Ctrl C im Terminal Kommando cancel ist. Guck. Also wenn ich was
laufen habe und dann muss ich jetzt Ctrl C drücken, um das abzubrechen. Deswegen kannst
du nicht zum Kopieren. Ctrl V geht, das ist nicht weiter belegt. Wenn du Ctrl S drückst,
hast du ein Problem, dann hängt dein Terminal, nehme ich. Und dazu musst du wieder, fragt
mir nicht irgendwas anderes drücken, dass es wieder weggeht. Ja, es ist es ist GPU Accelerated
und weil es so krass GPU Accelerated ist. Lackt es hinterher. Kann eigentlich nicht
sein, oder? Wir können wir können mal Software. Wo war das denn mit dem Software? L. S.
Ah, Show Keys haben wir auch. Image Cat. Ach guck mal, das kann das direkt auch oder oder
oder wie? Das ist doch nice. Anime Excited GIF. Leute, das ist ja noch viel besser. Das
in West Ham eingebaute Image Cat. Da brauchen wir doch dieses diesen anderen Krempel gar
nicht. Dann steht es auch an der richtigen Stelle. Easy. Noch viel besser. Also bei mir
guck mal, bei mir leckt das, wenn ich gedrückt halte und jetzt loslasse. Wie war das nochmal
mit dem Frontend? Frontend Software. Nee, das Software. Okay, Frontend OpenGL ist Default.
Frontend OpenGL. Und jetzt machen wir gleich mal Frontend Software hinten drauf. Also
hier lags, wobei das nicht an dem Rändern von der GPU oder sonst was liegt. Das kommt
einfach mit dem Ausführen irgendwie nicht hinterher. Software. Wenn ich das hier weg
mache, dann sollte es nicht gehen. Genau. Did you mean Software? Alter, guck mal, der
ist sogar so high IQ und hat ein Auto Complete fürs Terminal drin. Lul. Guck mal. Kann man
das hier wieder zumachen? Nope. No Pass. Wie kriege ich das wieder zu? Ah, so. Nee,
laggt immer noch ein bisschen. Nee, nee. Laggt immer noch ein bisschen hinterher. Naja,
gut, gibt, gibt, gibt Schlimmeres. Animation FPS. Ja, also einen blinkenden Cursor will
ich schon haben. Ohne blinkenden Cursor ist das stimmt. Mir fehlt, mir fehlt ein bisschen
was. Mir fehlt ein bisschen was. Blinken der Cursor muss sein. Na klar. Aber es blinkt
der Cursor nicht. Ah, ist er auch constant. Cursor. Meinst du der Scrollback Buffer? Wie
macht man den Lua in den Comment? So? Ey, das ist nicht das Scrollback Buffer. Ach doch,
jetzt geht's. Guck mal. Legt das wirklich? Leute, legt das wirklich an meinem Scrollback
Buffer? Der zu groß ist? Auch wenn er noch gar nicht gefüllt ist? Okay. Scrollback Lines.
Fünf. Nee. Hä? Jetzt ist es wieder da. Moment, wenn ich's an der... Jetzt blicke ich nicht
mehr durch. Wenn ich hier, wenn ich hier den Syntax... Okay Leute, ich... Jetzt geht's
wieder. Also irgendwas von meinen Settings macht es langsam. Ohne jetzt zu wissen, was...
Lua Comments sind Minus Minus. Ah, yes. Nee, das macht's langsam. Okay, das muss ich jetzt
nicht verstehen, oder? Irgendwas in meiner Config macht's langsam. Und was könnte was
könnte das sein? Ups. Was, was... Ich mein, wir können jetzt einfach... Oh, die Maus-Dings
beim Reinklicken muss ich auch ausschalten. Wir kommentieren einfach alles aus. Gucken
wir mal, ob's dann wieder so lahm ist. Oh, bam. Jetzt ist es, jetzt ist es schnell. So
halbwegs. Ui. Oh, Color, Color Scheme. Das Color Scheme... Moment, das macht es langsam?
Die Colors machen das langsam? Hä? Nee, die Colors sind das. Jetzt ist es blazingly fast
und mit den Colors ist es langsam. Wie ist denn das in meiner anderen VM? Im GNOME Terminal
hiermit? Das ist, ey, das ist mega schnell. Oder man sieht's, man sieht's, man sieht's
vielleicht nicht. Man sieht, man sieht's vielleicht nur nicht. Okay, wir machen noch einen ordentlichen
Prompt jetzt rein. Wir machen jetzt noch einen ordentlichen Prompt und dann gucken wir uns
das Ganze noch mal an. Ich wollte eh Starship mal ausprobieren. Also die Scrollback, Scrollback
ist es schon mal nicht. Scrollback Lines, können wir hier volle Pole reinhauen. Okay,
ähm... Starship wollte ich ausprobieren. Starship RS. Starship Cross Shell Prompt. Getting
started. Also aktuell verwende ich Pure Prompt. Warum hab ich eigentlich keine Colour-Ausgabe?
Liegt das einer meiner Bash-RC, die da keine Colour hat oder wie? Ich mein, normalerweise...
Guck dir mal. Normalerweise hab ich... Oder hat Jager keine Colour-Ausgabe? Doch, ich
glaub schon. Okay. Pure Prompt. Ja guck mal, hier sind Farben drin. Warum hat das... Warum
hat das hier keine Colours? Echt, die defaults Colours sind die aus? Wirklich? Ach in der
Pacman Conf? Ah ja, das kann sein. Der benutzt auch die Pacman Conf. Hallo. Einfach nur so
oder was? Ah, easy. Das wusste ich gar nicht mehr. Das hab ich schon vor... Hier Parallel
Downloads müssen wir auch noch einschalten und sowas. Das hab ich vor 30 Milliarden Jahren
mal eingeschaltet, das wusste ich gar nicht mehr. Das war... Wusste ich gar immer, dass
es default ist. Okay. Also aktuell verwende ich den hier Pure... Äh, das gibt es doch
als Package. Na gut, wie auch sei. Starship. Cross Shell Prompt für Astronauts. Okay.
I Love Candy, was macht das denn? Pacman, I Love Candy. Okay. Ach hier, das ist der
Mini Pacman. Ja. Also, Installation haben wir schon. Set up your shell to use Starship.
Ja aktuell hab ich noch Bash, das ist zum ausprobieren auch gar nicht so verkehrt. Leute,
Plasingly fast. Sind wir hier, Plasingly fast, guck mal. Mit Starship. Das Gelege ist aber
schon fragwürdig, ja. Und es ist das Color Scheme, was es so langsam macht, ist ja noch
schlimmer. Was ist Elvish für eine Shell? Wie viele Shells gibt es denn mittlerweile?
Okay, Presets. Was nehmen wir da Schönes? Nerd Fond Symbols. Okay, gehen wir mal in
irgendein Projekt rein. Also gehen wir mal zum Beispiel hier. Repos 4 Champ. On Master.
Genau. Starship Preset. Warum muss man das überhaupt irgendwie? Ach so, ach der legt
dann einfach nur eine Config für einen an. Muss man das jetzt irgendwie reloaden? Muss
man Starship jetzt irgendwie neu starten oder so? Starship Reload. Reload. Äh, achso.
Ich bin natürlich wieder zu blöd gewesen. Ich brauch mein Keyboard, mein Clipboard Manager,
sonst hab ich ja. Ach, ist das der Default? Kann das sein, dass ich gerade den Default
einfach benutzt habe? No Nerd Symbols. Okay. Oh, jetzt gibt es, jetzt gibt es. Crack it
oder gibt es Emojis? Das ist wichtig. Ohne Emojis geht da nichts. Nee. Also, Presets,
Pure Prompt. Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Das sollte, das sollte dann aussehen
wie mein alter Prompt, nur dass es. Ach ja, nee, das reloadet tatsächlich automatisch.
Das reloadet tatsächlich automatisch. Repos 4 Champ. Naja, fast, fast. So die Symbols,
die stimmen nicht so ganz. Normalerweise habe ich hier jetzt noch Touch, dass irgendwelche
Dateien drin sind. Naja, nee, passt eigentlich. Okay, was haben wir sonst noch für Presets?
Ich will jetzt nichts groß Customer essen, weil das ist wieder eine Sache von, von 5
Stunden. Oh, das. Von M365Princess. Alles klar, das brauche ich jetzt. M365Princess. Nice.
Excellent. M365Princess. Das Gelegge ist aber schon ein bisschen doof. M365Princess, Leute.
Das ist ein bisschen schlecht lesbar mit meinem, mit meinem Farbschieben. Haben wir sonst noch
für Presets? Tokio Knight. Oh, das ist für alle Apple, für alle Apple Fans. Pure Prompt.
Bracketed Segments. Das finde ich auch gar nicht übel. Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Ja, das sieht schön clean aus. Das sieht schön clean aus. Das gefällt mir. Also, seriously,
ich will bestimmt kein Apple Icon da vorne haben. Dann bleiben wir lieber bei Bracketed
Segments, alles klar. Eigentlich ganz nett, oder? Ist doch eigentlich ganz nett. Das sieht
relativ clean aus. So, und da kann man jetzt anscheinend sich auch irgendwie die.NET,
die.NET-Version und sowas anzeigen lassen. Das muss ich noch mal ausprobieren. Advanced
Configuration.NET. Wir machen ja viel.NET-Sachen im Stream. So, und wie geht das jetzt? Macht
es jetzt vielleicht standardmäßig schon? Hier, Champ Addon. Hier, Client. Ach, gucke
mal da. Das macht es schon. Das hat doch was. Ich muss sagen, dass so lässt sich das doch
arbeiten, oder? Das Terminal ist ganz cool. Der Prompt ist in den Default-Settings jetzt
alles so verkehrt. Da werde ich auf jeden Fall in Zukunft noch ein bisschen dran rumbasteln,
aber es gab Samstag noch nie auf Wachstreams. Ach, guck, da ist der noch drinne. Ah, nee,
Moment, Tokio Night! Scheiße. Bracketed Segments. Das gefällt mir. Das ist nice. Das werde
ich erst mal so lassen. Hier vorne das Icon werde ich noch austauschen oder irgendwas anderes.
Das ist nice. Und ja, man sieht auch, ob es Error gegeben hat beim letzten Command. Sehr
schick, sehr schick. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Das gefällt mir. Das Einzige, was mich ein
bisschen nervt, ist, dass es so laggy ist im Terminal. So, und das liegt wahrscheinlich,
das muss an diesem Colorscheme liegen. Machen wir mal hier Lua Commons, weil auch immer...
Wer hat sich in Lua eigentlich ausgedacht, Minusminus wäre was Gutes? So, Batman ist
das Default-Theme. Das ist viel schneller, Leute. Ui. Nee. Auch nicht. Was ist denn das?
Sobald ich ein Colorscheme drinne habe, ist es langsam. What the fuck? Was ist denn das?
What the fuck? Das kann doch nicht sein. Das muss doch irgendein Bug sein. Sobald Colorscheme
gesetzt ist in der Config, ist es langsam. So, guck mal. Instant. Ich höre auf zu drücken.
Zack. Nee. Guck mal. Batman ist sogar das Default-Colorscheme. Das ist exakt das Gleiche.
Und jetzt ist es langsam und mit dem Default-Colorscheme nicht gesetzt ist es schnell und das Default-Colorscheme
gesetzt ist es langsam. What? Keine echte GPU? Ich habe sogar schon auf Software-Rendering
gestellt. Macht aber auch keinen Unterschied. 100 FPS-Animationen. Bam, bababam. Sobald
das drinne ist. Langsam. Hä? Wie mache ich einen Blinking-Western-Blinking-Cursor? Cursor-Blink-Rate.
800. Exzellent. Aber der Cursor blinkt nicht. Das machen wir wieder raus. Der Cursor blinkt
nicht. How often a blinking-Cursor-Setting is? Ja. Cursor blinkt? Was zum? Okay, das
ist higher que blinken Cursor hinzubekommen. Sehe ich schon. Cursor blinken? Vielleicht
blinkt er zu schnell? Meinst du? Meinst du? Ich soll es mal auf 8. Westerm-Cursor das
nicht blinken. Der blinkt mit 800 FPS. Nee, das ist Millisekunden steht doch da. Wie viele
Millisekunden der blinken soll? Also aktuell ist es kein Unterschied, ob der auf 0 steht
oder auf 5. Der blinkt einfach gar nicht. Juckt ihn. Juckt ihn nicht. Vielleicht hat
das ja wirklich was mit meinen Animation-FPS 999 zu tun. Wow. Out of range. Anzeige ist
raus. 100. 100 FPS please. Der blinkt nicht. Der hat einfach keinen Bock zu blinken. Tja.
Das ist immer. Mit so einfachen Sachen ist es dann. Da muss, aber guck mal, man kann
unglaublich viel konfigurieren. Das ist schon mal, das ist schon mal sehr nice. Westerm-Color-Schemie.
Slow. Very slow when typing. Wir könnten es unter Windows mal installieren und gucken,
wie es sich da verhält. Aber das nächste Mal dann. Das ist nicht auch noch. Aber wir
suchen mal nach slow. Wahrscheinlich ist das Ding eine Konfig-Option. Text-Splink-Rate.
Slow. Multiplexing is very slow. Is really slow.
Ah, das. Eigentlich habe ich. Also, ja.
Egal. Ich blende das mal wieder ein. Aber hübsch ist es. Das hat schon was. Und man
kann GIFs anzeigen. Das überzeugt mich natürlich komplett. Warte mal. Wir probieren das jetzt
mal kurz aus. Westerm-Releases. Windows. Setup. Auf geht's. Zack. Das muss ich jetzt mal
kurz ausprobieren. Windows. Setup Excel. Du du du du du du du du du du du. Ja. Aha.
Oh nein. Und gleich mal als Admin. Gib ihm. Direkt. Direkt den Virus am Start. Launch
Westerm. Ach so. Windows. Windows CMD. Oh MonkaS. Wo liegt man hier überhaupt? Oh Gott.
Windows. Explorer Punkt. Wie konfiguriert man das überhaupt unter Windows jetzt? Set
Maus. Vim muss auf jeden Fall die Maus aus. Sonst kriegt man ja Anfälle. Oh fuck. Siehste
deswegen kopiere ich gerne mit der rechten. Muss Vim konfig. Muss weg. Deswegen kopiere
ich gerne mit der rechten Maustaste. So kann man jetzt einfach in seinem Home eine Punkt
Westerm Punkt Lua anlegen? Wahrscheinlich nicht oder? Windows. Please. Nicht CMD. Windows.
Jetzt muss ich muss ich noch Moven oder? Move Westerm Lua nach Westerm Lua. Okay, das funktioniert
so schon mal nicht. Wo? Okay. Westerm Lua Konfig Windows. Wo kommt die Konfig unter
Windows überhaupt hin? Aha. Aha. Hier. Leute, ich hab keinen Bock das unter Windows auszuprobieren.
Das ist mir zu dumm. Da hab ich keine Kraft drauf. Uninstall. Wo ist es? Warum kann man
da nicht drinnen suchen? Was will das von mir man? Remove. Westerm. Warum gibt es da eigentlich
schon wieder 50 verschiedene Dinger? Yes. Yes. Gut. Und Tschüss. Vielleicht ist es
ein Bug in VMWR. Na, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Aber insgesamt finde ich es cool. Das gefällt
mir. Das gefällt mir wirklich gut. Nächstes Mal gucken wir uns noch. Ich muss mir das mal
speichern fürs nächste Mal, weil ich lösche das sonst. Jetzt gucken wir uns das nächste
Mal ein paar Sachen an. Wann die Stay Reaction? Morgen beim Aufwach Stream. Sonst wird das
nichts mehr. Ihr müsst mich morgen dran erinnern. Leute, reicht mir. Genug rumgebasteln. Aber
das ist eine Kombination. Damit kann man, glaube ich, leben. Das finde ich schon mal ganz
nice. Die Performance ist noch ein bisschen... Na ja. Es wurde noch nichts reactet. Es hat
wohl jemand auf irgendein Video von mir reactet. Es hat irgendjemand auf meinen YouTube-Wurde,
Angriff auf meinen YouTube-Kanal, Hacker-Man-Zeug reactet. Haben wir eine Frage? Aber wo
könnte man besser sagen? Auf KVM oder VM? KVM. KVM ist das einzige, wo du sinnvollerweise
deine GPU durchreichen kannst. Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, spielen in der VM... Ja, also, nur
weil es geht, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass man das machen muss. Vor allem, weil du kannst
knicken. Vor allem, weil du kannst knicken, weil du kannst nicht auf deinem laufenden System
vor allem bei Workstations installieren und dann die Grafikkarte durchreichen. Das funktioniert
nicht. Wenn du einfach nur ein bisschen, wenn du einfach nur etwas Altes spielen willst
und ein bisschen 3D-Beschleunigung brauchst, das geht vielleicht mit VM und Workstation
ganz gut, dann musst du dich nicht mit GPU-Path-Through und sowas beschäftigen. Das geht dann besser
wie mit KVM. Aber wenn du GPU-Path-Through machen willst... Richtig, du brauchst zwei
GPUs. Du müsstest dann auf dem Host beispielsweise die onboard... Du brauchst doch zwei Monitore.
Nicht zwangsläufig. Du kannst so was wie Looking Glass oder wie heißt der Krempel
machen. Also du kannst quasi das abgreifen. Dann gibt es noch sowas wie V... Nee, wie
heißt das? Wird GPU oder sowas? Das habe ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert. Also Spiele
in der VM kann man machen, aber ich weiß nicht nur, wenn man es machen kann, ob man das wirklich
machen sollte. Also Leute, 4 Stunden, das reicht mir jetzt echt. Lange genug rumgebastelt,
war auf jeden Fall nice. Wieder viele neue Sachen gesehen, ausprobiert. Terminal-Kombination
finde ich wirklich nice. Ich glaube, das werde ich in Zukunft verwenden. Es muss bloß Performance
technisch irgendwie noch getunet bekommen. Es kann nicht sein, dass wenn ich ein bisschen
die Enter-Taste gedrückt halte und dann Clear mache, dass ich dann kurze Verzögerungen
merke. Das muss wirklich nicht sein. Alles klar. Leute, wir sehen uns. Ich gehe jetzt
erstmal was trinken und aufs Klo. Und dann sehen wir uns morgen früh wieder zum Aufwachen.
Bis dann, macht's gut, CO.